Okay, so we are a low audience. We're backstage. We're supposed to be doing a cold open, like a podcast right now. We did a cold open, we should have prepared. Right, we don't have anything ready to say. We're just doing mindless talking. We should maybe say, don't take flash photography or record the show. But introduce yourself, maybe you do that.
好吧，所以我们有很多观众。我们在后台。我们现在本来应该做一个冷开场，就像播客那样。我们做了冷开场，我们本该做点准备的。对吧，我们什么都没准备好。我们只是在胡言乱语。我们也许应该说，不要用闪光灯拍照或录制节目。但介绍一下你自己，也许你可以这么做。
Okay, my name is Sean. Yeah, my name is Will. And you hold for the plot. Yeah, maybe you do that. Okay, my name is Sean. My name is Will. And you hold for the applause. Yeah, just on a different time. So, and I am Jason. Yeah. And did you say you were Will? No, but it was in the, my name is Will.
好吧，我叫肖恩。对，我叫威尔。而你要静候剧情发展。对，也许你可以这么做。好吧，我叫肖恩。我叫威尔。而你要静候掌声。对，只是在不同的时间。所以，我是杰森。对。你刚才说你叫威尔吗？不，但它在，我叫威尔。
You do need to wake up just a little bit. I'm sorry. That's epic. That's epic. Okay. Ready? Here we go. Welcome to Smart Loss! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run Run! Run! Run! Run! Run Run! Run Run! Run! Run! Run! Run Run! Run! Run Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run Run! Run Run! Run Run! Run! Run! Run Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run! Run Oh
你确实需要稍微清醒一点。我很抱歉。太绝了。太绝了。好吧。准备好了吗？我们开始吧。欢迎来到“聪明亏损”（SmartLess）！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！跑！噢
Oh See Tracy from Wisconsin shirts look at these guys By the way tell him Tracy's here. Tracy's here. Yeah. So you're going to come out and say hi. Where is he? Come out and say hi.
噢，看来自威斯康星州的特蕾西穿着这件衬衫，看看这些家伙。顺便告诉他特蕾西来了。特蕾西来了。对。所以你要出来打个招呼。他在哪？出来打个招呼。
Come on, just say hi. Tracy, come on. Guys, guys, guys, they're high. Look at this. Look at these guys. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this.
来吧，打个招呼就行。特蕾西，来吧。伙计们，伙计们，伙计们，他们嗑嗨了。看看这个。看看这些家伙。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。
Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this.
看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。
看看这个。看看这个。看看这个. 看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。
Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. Look at this. I think you're not regretting. Yes, I am not that you know, or maybe you do know or care. I'm from here. Yeah. Yeah. As Jason said, we're so glad you wanted to meet us. And we wanted to meet you. And the tour was the only way we could do it. So thank you.
看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看 هذا。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。看看这个。我想你不会后悔的。是的，我不是说你知道，或者也许你知道或在乎。我是从这来的。对。对。正如杰森所说，我们很高兴你想见我们。我们也想见你。而巡演是我们能做到这一点的唯一方式。所以谢谢你。
Thank you. I just had to do it. It was just yelling at me. That was really hard. I was just happy before we came out. Why are you hitting me? It's really fun. No, no, no, no.
谢谢你。我就是不得不这么做。它一直在对我大喊大叫。那真的很难。在我们出来之前我正高兴着呢。你为什么打我？这真的很有趣。不，不，不，不。
Here we go. This is a dream come true for you, right? Yes. You said you left Chicago many moons ago to drive to Los Angeles and you said, one day I'm going to come back here with my podcast. That's right. That's right.
我们开始吧。这对你来说是个梦想成真，对吧？是的。你说你很久以前离开芝加哥开车去洛杉矶，你说，总有一天我要带着我的播客回到这里。没。没错。
You made it. That's everybody's dream. Right. But anyway, thank you for being here. We're going to sit on the couch now. All right, let's do it. All right. All right.
你成功了。那是每个人的梦想。对。但无论如何，谢谢你能来。我们现在要坐在沙发上了。好吧，我们开始吧。好吧。好吧。
All right. All right. Well, I got to to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it.
好吧。好吧。好吧，我得听听这个。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。
Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it.
哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。
Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen to it. Oh, I'll listen University. What? The best school in the world. I'll tell you a little story. I don't know if I-
哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。哦，我会听的。大学。什么？世界上最好的学校。我给你讲个小故事。我不知道我是不是——
The school in the world is there, okay? Yeah, best school in the world. Just gotta talk. And I'm gonna tell you a little quick story about my experience there. One time I was so wasted freshman year. By the way, Waters and Towers, you know, Waters and Towers, okay. So Waters and Towers was great. It's the tallest year. By the way, water's in towers. You know, water's in towers. Okay.
世界上最好的学校就在那，好吗？对，世界上最好的学校。我得讲讲。我要给你讲个关于我在那里的经历的简短小故事。有一次我大一的时候喝得酩酊大醉。顺便说一句，沃特斯和托尔斯（Waters and Towers），你知道的，沃特斯和托尔斯，好吧。所以沃特斯和托尔斯很棒。那是最高的一年。顺便说一句，沃特斯和托尔斯。你知道的，沃特斯和托尔斯。好吧。
Ah! So water's in towers is great. It's the tallest dorm building in the country, which is true. It is the tallest dorm building in the country. So if you went to a party on the outskirts and you got just fucking wasted, all you had to do, I remember coming home from parties
啊！所以沃特斯和托尔斯很棒。那是全国最高的宿舍楼，千真万确。它确实是全国最高的宿舍楼。所以如果你去郊外的派对喝得他妈的烂醉，你唯一要做的，我记得从派对回家时
like this, I was like, oh my God, I don't know where I am. Oh, I just go there. I would walk to the waters and towers, because it was so easy. But one time, I think one of those nights, I was intoxicated, I went to a white hen, which now, remember white hen? Oh.
就像这样，我当时想，天哪，我不知道我在哪。哦，我直接去那儿就行。我会步行去沃特斯和托尔斯，因为那太简单了。但有一次，我想在其中的一个夜晚，我喝醉了，我去了一家白母鸡便利店（White Hen），现在，还记得白母鸡吗？哦。
And I was... How was it compared to Portillo's? Well, white hen is 7-Eleven, basically. Okay, okay, got, sorry. Sorry. So, okay, got it. Sorry. Sorry. He's from Canada. So, I went in there and I was really drunk. I was with my friend Randy, who you guys just met.
然后我……跟波蒂略（Portillo's）比起来怎么样？嗯，白母鸡基本上就是7-Eleven。好吧，好吧，明白了，对不起。对不起。所以，好吧，明白了。对不起。对不起。他来自加拿大。所以，我走进去的时候真的喝醉了。我和我的朋友兰迪（Randy）在一起，你们刚才也见过他。
And I was so drunk, I had no money, and I stole a turkey sandwich, right? And so, I went into the... Whoa, you shoplifted it? I shoplifted a turkey sandwich, because I was really hungry. Have you ever shoplifted? No.
我醉得厉害，身上没钱，然后我偷了一个火鸡三明治，对吧？然后，我走进了……哇，你顺手牵羊了？我顺手牵羊拿了一个火鸡三明治，因为我真的太饿了。你曾经顺手牵羊过吗？没有。
I never have. All right, so I go in there and I'm like, oh, this is, you know, I'll be cool and I'll get to eat. So it was like, and I put a turkey sandwich in my bag. And literally, I go out and sit in front of the white hen and I'm just eating and I'm throwing the tomatoes at cars because I don't like the tomatoes. And all of a sudden, we're all laughing,
我从来没有过。好吧，所以我走进去，心想，哦，这，你知道的，我要装酷，然后我能有东西吃。所以就像是，我把一个火鸡三明治塞进包里。真的，我走出去坐在白母鸡便利店外面，我一边吃一边把西红柿扔向汽车，因为我不喜欢西红柿。突然间，我们都在大笑，
and all of a sudden, I see this cop's feet right in front of me. And I look up and I was like, oh, my God. And I got arrested. And so, yeah, I got arrested for stealing a turkey sandwich. And in the back seat, I was such an asshole. I was in the back seat, like, right around on the, like, so drunk and he goes, I go, hey, isn't there somebody getting murdered somewhere? Like, why are you arresting a guy that got in your mouth?
突然间，我看到一双警察的脚就在我面前。我抬起头，心想，哦，天哪。然后我就被捕了。所以，是的，我因为偷了一个火鸡三明治被捕了。在警车后座上，我当时混蛋透顶。我坐在后座上，比如，在那个上面，醉得一塌糊涂，然后他对我说，我说，嘿，难道没有人在某个地方被谋杀吗？拜托，你为什么抓一个……
I'm running in your mouth. I'm so in Turkey. I'm running in my mouth. Turkey sandwich. Isn't there something more important? Anyway, so I go to the thing. It costs 100 bucks to get bailed out. My, I called one of my brothers.
我在你嘴里胡扯。我醉得满嘴火鸡味。火鸡三明治。难道没有更重要的事情吗？不管怎样，我去办了那个手续。保释金要100块钱。我，我给我的一个兄弟打了电话。
They weren't around. And then this guy, Liam, who does the longest story in the world, Liam bailed me out. He was in the theater department. I didn't know him. And then, cut to like 15 years later. He gave me a hundred bucks, and I bailed. And then I paid back. This is Bateman Length Awful.
他们不在。然后这家伙利亚姆（Liam），他讲了一个世上最长的故事，利亚姆把我保释了出来。他在戏剧系。我不认识他。然后，镜头一转，大约15年过去了。他给了我一百块钱，我保释了。然后我还了钱。这简直就是巴特曼式的糟糕长篇故事。
Yeah, yeah. So wait. So then 15 years later, I'm at Swinger's Unbeverly, which is a diner. Sure. Yeah. And he's my waiter, the guy which is a diner. Sure, yeah. And he's my waiter, the guy who bailed me out. What?
对，对。等等。所以15年后，我在贝弗利的斯温格斯（Swinger's），那是一家 diner（餐馆）。没错。对。而他是我的服务员，那个把我保释出来的家伙，那是一家 diner。没错，对。而他是我的服务员，那个把我保释出来的家伙。什么？
Isn't that good story, right? That's it. Yes. Yes. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Was that the only time you've ever, only time you've ever been arrested? Uh, yeah.
这不是个好故事吗？就是这样。是的。是的。等等，等等，等等，等等。那是你唯一一次，唯一一次被捕吗？呃，是的。
Hang on. No one has to think that long about what that pause usually means Should I say about the other three times I got arrested? No, no I didn't I never got arrested, but I do have a great masturbation story too if you want to hear that Well buckle up everybody But hang on second your next really red right here. You okay? It's just on this side. Yeah, because you fucking slept with me. What happened? No, it's not.
等一下。没人需要花那么长时间去想那个暂停通常意味着什么。我是不是该说说另外三次我被捕的经历？不，不，我没有，我从来没有被捕过，但我确实还有一个很棒的手淫故事，如果你想听的话。好吧，大家系好安全带。但等一下，你的脖子真的红了一片。你没事吧？就在这边。对，因为你他妈的和我在一块儿。发生了什么？不，不是的。
It's not. So when I was a kid, my dad's mom, my grandma on that side. So it's already a good story. Yeah. It's a... We're already off to a booming start. So she used to crochet all these animals. They were really cute.
不是的。所以当我还是个孩子的时候，我爸爸的妈妈，我那一边的奶奶。所以这已经是个好故事了。对。这是一个……我们已经开局大吉了。所以她以前会钩织所有这些动物。它们真的很可爱。
She would give them to us. Like, they were like pre-shaped animals. Like, there was a dinosaur and a duck and like a mouse and a dog. And she would, you know, they had the form, but you crocheted around them. And so she gave us these things. And I used to cut out the whole of the dinosaurs
她会把它们送给我们。就像是，它们是那种预先成型的动物。比如，有一个恐龙、一只鸭子、还有一只老鼠和一只狗。然后她会，你知道的，它们有模子，但你在它们外面钩织。所以她把这些东西送给我们。而我以前会把恐龙的整个部位
by mouth, and I used to fuck it. Wait. You know, there's a 5,000 people out here. Wait. Okay, so wait, so wait. Oh, good, there's more. Wait, did it matter what kind of dinosaur, like would you not get turned on by a Tyrannosaurus Rex,
用嘴套住，然后我操它。等等。你知道这里有5000人吗？等等。好吧，所以等等，所以等等。哦，太好了，还有。等等，恐龙的种类有关系吗？比如你不会对霸王龙产生性冲动，
but definitely a Bronx. One dinosaur. And the mouth was stuck open like that, so I looked at it, I was like, I'll just cut a whole hand, bye. Yeah. So then, so then I do this, right? And then I see all other kids coming over to play with and I'm like, ugh, God have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have to have You got to tell the story of my friend. Oh, because everybody does the masturbate, will. Not in the story of my friend.
但对雷龙绝对会？只有一只恐龙。它的嘴就那样张开着，我看着它，心想，我就切个洞，拜拜。对。所以，然后，所以我这样做了，对吧？然后我看到其他孩子过来一起玩，我就想，呃，天哪，得，得，得，得，得，得……你得讲讲我朋友的故事。哦，因为每个人都在手淫，威尔。不是我朋友的故事。
Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend.
不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。
Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend.
不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。
Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. Not in the story of my friend. then I share them with you. And now you because you're my friends. Jason, have you been arrested? Oh, I know that's nice. So masturbation stories really bring people together? It does make that story cuter. Uh, Jason arrested. Arrested, development.
不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。不是我朋友的故事。然后我把它们分享给你们。现在因为你们是我的朋友。杰森，你被捕过吗？哦，我知道这很好。所以手淫故事真的能把人们拉近？这确实让那个故事更可爱了。呃，杰森被捕。逮捕发展史。
Great show. Oh. Oh, wait, wait. Sean, favorite scene go What was the name of his character? Joe I used to call it gob because I didn't know until like yesterday Well, yeah, I want to know I want to know worst arrested stories not the show rested from the cops I did I spent one night in jail
好剧。哦。哦，等等，等等。肖恩，最喜欢的场景是？他的角色叫什么名字？乔。我以前叫他戈布（gob），因为我直到昨天才知道。好吧，对，我想知道，我想知道最糟糕的被捕故事，不是指那个剧，而是被警察逮捕。我确实……我在局子里呆了一晚。
But in I think I may have even told some podcast. Monaco, yeah. I'm so old. I'm right, right. Yeah, it was in, yeah, it was in Monaco, and they gave me a pagemina, because I was cold. It's like real soft. Oh, and I did, I have to spend three innings
但在……我想我甚至可能在某些播客里讲过。摩纳哥，对。我太老了。我没说错，对吧。对，那是在，对，那是在摩纳哥，他们给了我一条开司米披肩（pashmina），因为我很冷。那真是超级柔软。哦，我确实，我不得不在
in Dodger Jail, because I got a little over served in about the sixth inning, and I had to cool off up in the Dodger Jail on the upper deck. Saul painted Dodger Blue, it's fun. And you're not allowed to see the end of the game. That's the punishment. And then they turn you loose. Canada seems like a reward. What about you, little hellcat?
道奇球场监狱里度过三局，因为我在大约第六局时喝得有点多，我不得不到上层的道奇球场监狱冷静一下。那里刷成了道奇蓝，挺有趣的。而且你不被允许看比赛的结尾。这就是惩罚。然后他们把你放了。加拿大听起来像是个奖励。你呢，小泼妇？
Did you ever spend- Never arrested. I shoplifted once. I stole a bag of chips when they were 25 years old. What about you, little hellcat? Did you ever spend- Yeah, never arrested. And I did, I shoplanted once. I stole a bag of chips when they were like 25 cents. And I felt so bad the next day I went back into the convenience store. I was about 11, and I put a quarter on the counter
你有没有——从来没被抓过。我顺手牵羊过一次。当它们只要25美分的时候，我偷了一包薯片。你呢，小泼妇？你有没有——对，从来没被捕过。而且我确实，我顺手牵羊过一次。当它们大约25美分的时候，我偷了一包薯片。我第二天感到非常糟糕，以至于我走回了那家便利店。我当时大约11岁，我在柜台上放了一个25美分硬币
and walked out. True story. True story, that was it. Not as thrilling as mine, but that was the one. Oh, sorry. And then I fucked the bag of chips. LAUGHTER Are we back on track?
然后走了出去。真实的故事。真实的故事，就是这样。不如我的刺激，但这就是那次经历。哦，抱歉。然后我操了那包薯片。（笑声）我们回到正轨了吗？
LAUGHTER And then I saw the other kids eating it and I was like, oh, hey, hey, hey, you know what? We're having fun. Well, you can't, you just can't eat one. All right. So. Wow. Well, okay.
（笑声）然后我看到其他孩子在吃它，我就想，哦，嘿，嘿，嘿，你知道吗？我们玩得很开心。好吧，你不能，你就是不能只吃一个。好吧。所以。哇。好吧，好吧。
So, we're gonna get to the guest. I'm super excited. I'm sure I get to get to the guest. I'm super excited. I'm super excited. I'm super excited. We really don't know. Just again, we really don't believe that you guys know. We really don't know who it is. We really don't know. Just again, we really don't believe that you guys know.
所以，我们要迎接嘉宾了。我超级兴奋。我确信我能迎接嘉宾了。我超级兴奋。我超级兴奋。我超级兴奋。我们真的不知道。再说一次，我们真的不相信你们知道。我们真的不知道他是谁。我们真的不知道。再说一次，我们 really don't believe that you guys know.（我们真的不相信你们知道。）
We really don't know who it is. We really don't know. And it's a whole tour. We've done a really good job of sequestering the guests, so we have no idea who it is. So I wrote my thing like Jason does. So this guy's amazing. One of his quotes is, I love this quote.
我们真的不知道他是谁。我们真的不知道。这是一整场巡演。我们在隔离嘉宾方面做得非常好，所以我们完全不知道他是谁。所以我像杰森那样写了我的介绍词。所以这家伙太厉害了。他的名言之一，我特别喜欢这句名言。
It doesn't matter how many times you fail, you only have to be right once, and then everybody says you're an overnight success. His dad used to say, which I love this quote, today is the youngest you'll ever be, live like it. How great is that? I love that. He went from banking to bartending to business software.
不管你失败了多少次，你只需要对一次，然后每个人都说你是隔夜成名的天才。他爸爸常说——我非常喜欢这句话——今天是你此生最年轻的一天，活出个样来。这有多棒？我太喜欢了。他从银行业转行到调酒业，再到商业软件。
He's one of the pioneers of putting audio on the internet. He not only buys and sells companies. He's also immersed in the entertainment business as a co-owner of 29, 29 entertainment. He's not one of my favorite sharks. He is my favorite shark. It's Mark Cuban! What? Oh!
他是将音频带到互联网上的先驱之一。他不仅买卖公司。他还作为2929娱乐公司（2929 Entertainment）的联合所有人深深扎根于娱乐业。他不是我最喜欢的鲨鱼。他是我最喜欢的鲨鱼。他就是马克·库班（Mark Cuban）！什么？哦！
What? Let's go! Oh! Let's go! What? Oh! What's up? Wow!
什么？我们走！哦！我们走！什么？哦！怎么了？哇！
Thank you for having me on that. Thank you so much. Shit! Thank you, man. Thank think we have me on there. Thank you so much. Shit. Are you ring new? Nice to have you on there. Hey, Sean. Oh, yeah, absolutely. You love me right there.
谢谢你邀请我来。非常感谢。操！谢谢你，老兄。谢——谢谢你邀请我来。非常感谢。操。你是刚来的？很高兴你能来。嘿，肖恩。哦，对，绝对的。你很喜欢我吧。
Oh, look at this. What the shoes. What the shoes. Let's start with the shoes. Start with the shoes. Start with the shoes. Are those shoes? Now are you a sneaker head?
哦，看看这个。这鞋。这鞋。从鞋子开始吧。从鞋子开始。从鞋子开始。那是鞋子吗？现在你是个鞋头（sneakerhead）吗？
I'm not. I'm not really. Are those significant though? Those are significant. Tell us about them. There's a guy who plays on our team named Luca Dodget. Sure. Yeah. Sure. And he, these are his shoes. Oh, I got it.
我不是。我真的不是。不过那些很有意义吗？那些很有意义。跟我们讲讲吧。我们队里有个球员叫卢卡·东契奇（Luka Dončić）。当然。对。当然。而且他，这些是他的鞋。哦，我明白了。
Designed for him. And so every now and then I pull them out. Right. Like you should. Like I should. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You got to make the big guy happy. And out. Right. Like you should. Like I should. Yeah. Yeah, you got to make the big guy happy. And they're great.
为他设计的。所以每隔一段时间我就会把它们拿出来。对。就像你应得的那样。就像我应该的那样。对。对。对。你得让大个子高兴。出来。对。就像你应得的那样。就像我应该的那样。对。对，你得让大个子高兴。而且它们很棒。
And they match. Yeah. Look at you. That's great. Look at me. Sharp suit. Wow. And by the way, we were going to do, fly you out like real nice,
而且很搭配。对。看看你。太棒了。看看我。帅气的西装。哇。顺便说一句，我们本来打算，像真正高级那样用飞机把你接来，
you know, because you were so nice to come on. He's like, I'll fly myself. Yeah. Not literally. Not literally. Yeah, I've been told. But, you know, it was pretty nice. But, I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that,
你知道的，因为你这么好肯来。他说，我自己坐飞机来。对。不是字面意义上的。不是字面意义上的。对，我听说过。但是，你知道的，这挺不错的。但是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，
but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that,
我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，
but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say that, but I'm gonna say and that's why. So, so, so, so, how do you buy a basketball team? You write a big mother fucking check, that's what you do.
我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，我要说的是，这就是原因。所以，所以，所以，所以，你怎么买下一支篮球队？你开一张他妈的巨额支票，这就是你的做法。
But they're not just sitting around, right? I mean, how long were you sort of clocking it and see, there might be an opportunity and like, how do you get a heads up on that? So, this was like 22 years ago, 99, 2000 season. I was a season ticket holder in the Mav's Raffle. Yeah. And I just made a lot of money. Yeah.
但他们不是就坐在那里闲着，对吧？我的意思是，你关注了多久，然后发现，这可能是一个机会，以及，你是怎么提前得到消息的？所以，那是大约22年前，99到2000赛季。我是小牛队季票持有者。对。而我刚刚赚了一大笔钱。对。
And so I go to the game and I'm like, by the way. By the way, here's a thing. That's good luck. I know. Yeah. But wait, here's the thing. It's like, we're all taught to not say things like that. Because we're like, you shouldn't like, slon it.
所以我去球场看比赛，心想，顺便说一句。顺便说一句，这里有个事。那是好运。我知道。对。但等等，这里有个事。就像，我们从小受到的教育是不要说那样的话。因为我们觉得，你不应该，你知道，拿这个吹嘘。
But I love that you do. You make a luckiest motherfucker in the entire world. I am proud to be your friend. You have consistently been pretty straight up and honest, you don't posture about it. You always say it as it is. That is great. I love that, yeah.
但我喜欢你这么做。你绝对是全世界最走运的混蛋。我很骄傲能成为你的朋友。你一直都非常直率和诚心，你不会为此装腔作势。你总是实话实说。这太棒了。我喜欢那样，对。
No, keep going. OK, so you got dirty, still wear a white badge. So you made it happen to make a ton of money. You're at the game. And it's the start of the season. And I'm there with you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that.
不，继续。好吧，所以你变坏了，依然穿着白色徽章。所以你创造了机会赚了一大笔钱。你在比赛现场。而那是赛季初。我在那儿，你会因此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。
So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that.
所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。
So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on that. So you would get up on Right. Just like that? Just like that.
所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。所以你会为此振作起来。没错。就这么简单？就这么简单。
And what do you call to find out if they're even for sale? The guy. I mean, no. You call the guy? The guy. No. The owner was a guy named Ross Pro Jr. And didn't know or care anything about basketball.
那你给谁打电话去打听他们到底卖不卖？那个人。我的意思是，不。你给那个人打电话？那个人。不。老板是一个叫小罗斯·佩罗（Ross Perot Jr.）的人。而且他对篮球一无所知也不关心。
Wait, Ross Pro Jr.? Yeah. That was my first vote at 18. I voted for Ross Pro. Really? I really did. Yeah. I was so excited.
等等，小罗斯·佩罗？对。那是我18岁时的第一票。我投给了罗斯·佩罗。真的吗？我真的投了。对。我当时太兴奋了。
Oh, because I... Oh, you're the one. I was a big... I was a huge Dana Carvey fan. So I was like, let's do it. I have one Ross Pro story. I have one Ross Pro senior story. So my very first company after I got fired, I started this company, Micro Solutions, and the big deal. Yeah, we're talking about that too. And the big deal was, we had this big deal. That's what we do with Sean too.
哦，因为我……哦，原来你就是那个……我曾经是个超级……我曾是达纳·卡维（Dana Carvey）的超级粉丝。所以我当时想，就这样吧。我有一个罗斯·佩罗的故事。我有一个老罗斯·佩罗的故事。我被解雇后的第一家公司，我创办了这家公司，叫微型解决方案公司（MicroSolutions），这是一笔大买卖。对，我们也在谈论这个。这笔大买卖是，我们有一笔大交易。我们对肖恩也是这么做的。
Cool. Look at my story. And so I got a chance to do business with them. So we had a chance to do business with them. So we had this big deal. That's what we do with Sean too. Cool. That looks like my story. Yeah. And so I got a chance to do business with them. So he was like the big thing in Dallas. And I'm like 24 years old.
酷。看看我的故事。所以我得到了一个与他们做生意的机会。所以我们有机会与他们做生意。所以我们有一笔大交易。我们对肖恩也是这么做的。酷。这听起来像我的故事。对。所以我得到了一个与他们做生意的机会。所以他就像是达拉斯的大人物。而我当时24岁。
And so I get to go into this office. He's got the original Magna Carta. Wow. He's got the statue for Iwo Jima right there in his office. This is Ross Perot Jr. or senior? Senior, senior. The scariest moment of my life literally was walking down that hall hoping I did not destroy American history.
所以我得以走进这间办公室。他有原版的《大宪章》。哇。他的办公室里甚至还有硫磺岛雕像。这是小罗斯·佩罗还是老罗斯·佩罗？老罗斯，老罗斯。我一生中最吓人的时刻，真的就是走在那条走廊上，祈祷自己没有毁灭美国历史。
Right. Because there he was. No, leave that to other people. The other people, right. So of course you tried to stop that too. You tried to help out with that, too. Yeah, it did go so well the first time. But anyways, long story, sorry, I get to him, and I say, hi, Mr. Cuban, I'm Ross Pro.
对。因为他就坐在那儿。不，这种事留给别人吧。留给别人，对。所以你当然也试图阻止那个。你也试图帮忙解决那个，对。是的，第一次确实没那么顺利。不管怎样，长话短说，抱歉，我走到他面前，然后我说，嗨，库班先生，我是罗斯·佩罗。
No. Really? Oh, no. When you gave away your position, all your leverage was gone in that moment. Yeah, because a 24-year-old just started, has a ton of leverage. Yeah, so he laughed.
不对。真的吗？哦，不。当你主动暴露身份时，你所有的筹码在那一瞬间全都没了。对，因为一个刚创业的24岁年轻人掌握了海量的筹码。对，所以他笑了。
Wait, you were 24? Wait, when you were like, when you were almost 24 right now. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no 24-year-old just started as a ton of leverage, yeah, so he laughed. Wait, you were 24? 24, right? When you were almost 24, right now. No, no, no, no, no, no. Oh, when you did that. No, no, no.
等等，你当时24岁？等等，当你像……你现在快24岁了。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，派个24岁的刚创业者去谈判简直是天杰地灵，对，所以他笑了。等等，你24岁？24岁，对吧？当你差不多24岁的时候，现在。不，不，不，不，不，不。哦，当你做那个的时候。不，不，不。
When you met, when you met with senior. Yeah, that's right. I met with senior first time. So when I bought the team, right? So I got to meet junior. And literally from start to finish was about three weeks. Wow. Yeah.
当你见面时，当你跟老罗斯见面。对，没错。我第一次见老罗斯。所以当我买下球队的时候，对吧？所以我得以见到小罗斯。老实说，从开始到结束大约花了三周时间。哇。是的。
So he was an eager seller. He was an eager seller. And I, you know, he thought I was going to be a negotiation. And so when I sold, this was right in the middle of the internet stock boom, right? So literally, every day, the stock that I got from my company, from an old company called Yahoo, would go up $20. So it was like, wait, is Yahoo still around?
所以他是个急于脱手的人。他是个急于脱手的人。而我，你知道的，他以为我会是一场艰难的谈判。所以当我卖出时，这正值互联网股票泡沫的中心，对吧？所以真的，我从我的公司、从一家名为雅虎（Yahoo）的老公司那里得到的股票，每天都会上涨20美元。所以就像是，等等，雅虎现在还在吗？
Not really, no. Yeah, so you still look look, it's printed everywhere. It's like $5.7 billion. That's what they gave you. Well, they gave it to us and stock, and I got a third of that. OK, can I... Yeah.
不在了，真的不在了。对，所以你看，到处都印着呢。大约是57亿美元。那是他们给你的。嗯，他们是用股票给我们的，我拿了其中三分之一。好吧，我可以……对。
We deal with that third shit all the time. Oh, yeah, believe me. Uh, fuck. We just did it with cake from Portillo's. Yeah. So we actually did. We actually did. I don't mean to embarrass you, but I'm sure this is probably
我们整天都在处理那种三分之一的破事。哦，对，相信我。呃，操。我们刚才用波蒂略（Portillo's）的蛋糕也这么干了。对，所以我们确实这么做了。我不是故意让你尴尬，但我确信这可能
all public. What did you pay for the team and what is it worth now? So I paid $285 million. I love that you just see that. OK. Yeah. It's probably like a lie. It's probably a lie.
全是公开信息。你买下这支球队花了多少钱，现在它值多少钱？所以当时我花了2.85亿美元。我喜欢你直接说出来。好吧。对。这可能像个谎言。这可能是个谎言。
No, but it's unbelievable. Here's why. And so you can go on. Well, it's fine with me. We all did a ton of co-op before we came out here. I know. Can you tell it's not obvious? Wait, so you paid how much?
不，但这太难以置信了。原因如下。所以你可以继续。好吧，我无所谓。我们在来这儿之前都做了一大堆合作准备。我知道。你看得出来这很不明显吗？等等，所以你花了多少钱？
$285 million. That's crazy. And now it's worth, and I'm not $3 billion, $2.5 billion. Wow. It's only worth that if you're going to sell it, right? I have no plans. But all the teams have gone up exponentially bunch. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So it's like any kind of commodity, any kind of thing.
2.85亿美元。太疯狂了。现在它的价值——而且我不是……30亿美元，25亿美元。哇。只有当你打算卖掉它时，它才值那么多钱，对吧？我没有这个计划。但所有球队的价值都呈指数级暴涨。对，对，对。所以就像任何商品、任何事物一样。
It's like you invest in it like a house or whatever. And it's always kind of like a house. Like if you love your house, right? You bought the house and it's going up in value. If you bought a house for $235 million, it goes up because people love that sport. Yeah, yeah. So we've been fortunate and basketball's been very, love that the sport. Yeah, that, yeah. So, you know, we've been fortunate,
就像你投资房子或其他东西一样。而且它总是有点像房子。就像如果你热爱你的房子，对吧？你买下了房子，它的价值在上涨。如果你花2.35亿美元买了一栋房子，它就会上涨，因为人们热爱这项运动。对，对。所以我们一直很幸运，篮球一直非常——热爱这项运动。对，那，对。所以，你知道的，我们很幸运，
and basketball has been very, very good to me. Yeah. And so. That's crazy. So you were always in the sports, or specifically basketball? No, I've been. Yeah, not very well, but I've been a basketball junkie since I've been five years old. Are you disciplined about not sort of stepping on the toes
而且篮球对我一直非常好，非常好。所以。太疯狂了。所以你一直喜欢体育，还是专门喜欢篮球？不，我一直。对，虽然打得不是很好，但我从五岁起就是一个篮球迷。你在克制自己不去插手球队的运营方式这方面很有纪律性吗，还是他们希望你这么做？不，不。我想2.80亿美元。2.80亿美元。为了那个婊子养的花了2.80亿美元。我当然想干嘛就干嘛。
of the way in which the team is run, or do they want that? No, no. I think $280 million. $280 million. $280 million for that motherfucker. I get to do what I want. is sort of stepping on the toes of the way in which the team is run or do they want that? $25 million for that motherfucker. I get to do what I want. So, you're on the floor for a lot of games, if not all of them. In the middle of the game, will you go over and say to the head coach, hey man, you got to sit that guy down or I want him in the game. No, that I want to.
——或者他们希望你这么做？为了那个婊子养的花了2500万美元。我当然想干嘛就干嘛。所以，你现场观看很多比赛，如果不是全部的话。在比赛进行中，你会走过去对主教练说，嘿，老兄，你得让那家伙坐冷板凳，或者我要他上场。不，那个，我才不会。
That's where I draw the line. Now I might go to the referees and say what the fuck was that? But you are like famously, are you not the most fine, by far? Yeah, by far. Yeah, I love how proud you are of that.
那是我的底线。不过我可能会去找裁判说，刚才他妈的是怎么回事？但你可是出了名的——难道你不是被罚款最多的吗，遥遥领先？对，遥遥领先。对，我喜欢你为此感到骄傲。
But why? Because they get it wrong all the time. Who the fuck sets except that? So you get fine, you get fine by the referees. No, no, they wish, no, by the league, by the NBA. We're talking to the referees. No, no, they wish no by the league by the NBA We're talking for talking to the referees during the game more for saying something publicly after the game after the game I said your referee look. I'm sorry. I could have you killed That's what I would do if I if I was in your position. I would just look at I can go like this one time
但为什么呢？因为他们总是判错。谁他妈的会接受这个？所以你被罚款，你被裁判罚款。不，不，他们才希望呢，不，是被联盟，被NBA罚款。我们在说裁判的事。不，不，他们希望……不，是被联盟，被NBA。我们在比赛中对裁判说话，或者在赛后因为公开说了一些话。赛后我说，裁判，听着。我很抱歉。我本可以派人杀了你。如果我处在你的位置，我就会这么做。我就会看着然后说，有一次，
I went like this one time to a rapper. I got fine for that, yeah. Oh my God. That's crazy. Like I can't believe you own a team. OK. So it's just like, oh, and I have new pair of shoes and I own this team.
我曾对一个说唱歌手这样过。我因此被罚款了，对。天哪。太疯狂了。简直不敢相信你拥有一支球队。好吧。所以这就像是，哦，我有一双新鞋，而且我拥有一支球队。
OK. But wait, talk about microsolutions because what is it? And how did you start? I'm, say what you were going to say before. I was going to say, Sean was talking about his microsolutions earlier in Intro. Yeah, but I invested a lot of time in it and it grew and grew. So please.
好吧。但等等，谈谈微型解决方案公司吧，因为那是什么？你是怎么开始的？我，说你之前想说的话。我本想说，肖恩刚才在开场时提到了他的微型解决方案。对，但我花了很多时间在上面，它不断发展壮大。所以请继续。
So it was a grow or not a show or? That's it. No, it's a show or. So, no, so talking about microsolutions because, so I got fired from a show. No, it's a show. So, no, so talking about microstaticias, because, so I got fired from a job, right? So I was working in a job selling software and I had this deal, so step back. At the time, when I moved to Dallas
所以它是一个成长还是秀场？就是这样。不，是个秀场。所以，不，所以谈到微型解决方案，因为，我被一家公司解雇了。不，是个秀场。所以，不，所以谈到微型解决方案，因为，我被一份工作解雇了，对吧？所以我当时在一份销售软件的工作中，我谈成了一笔生意，所以退一步讲。当时，当我搬到达拉斯时
from Indiana University, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo, So after I went from IU down to Dallas, the only place I could live because I had no money. And so I lived in a shithole with five roommates. And literally, I didn't have a bathroom. I didn't have a room. I just had not even a closet. I just have a place that I just would sleep on, right? Like what year is this sort of? This is 1982.
来自印第安纳大学，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，噢，所以当我从印大搬到达拉斯时，由于身无分文，那是唯一我能住得起的地方。因此我和五个室友住在一个破公寓里。说实话，我甚至没有洗手间，没有自己的房间。我甚至连衣柜都没有，只有一个可以睡觉的地方，对吧？这大概是哪一年？这是1982年。
OK. Yeah. Way back when when I was six. Yeah. So six. Yeah, yeah. And so I got a job at night working as a bartender slash bar back and then during the day I got a job working as a software company. So I'm starving, right, and living in the shithole and I have a chance to close this big deal,
好吧。对。好久以前，那时我才六岁。对，六岁。对，对。所以我晚上找了一份工作，当酒保兼酒吧杂工，白天则在一家软件公司找到了一份工作。所以当时我快饿死了，对吧，住在一个破地方，而我有一个机会谈成一笔大生意，
right, and I'm going to get a $1,500 commission. I get to move out of the shithole. And so I go to my boss, you boss, normally I'm supposed to wipe down the windows and sweep the floor and open up the store. And I'm like, how Jason grew up, yeah. Really rough. Superly rough, yeah. Just that hot.
对吧，我能拿到1500美元的佣金。我终于能搬出那个破地方了。于是我去找我的老板，老板，通常我本该擦窗户、扫地、开店的。我就像，杰森是怎么长大的，对吧。真的非常艰难。超级艰难，对吧。就是那么艰难。
Fast food to fast food to fast food. And so I'm like, to my boss, a guy named Michael Humbecky, in case you're in into him. And so I'm like, I need to go pick up this check. And he goes, no, you have to open the store. And so I make the executive decision to go pick up the check. Yeah. Thinking if I hand him a $15,000 check,
从快餐到快餐，再到快餐。所以我对老板说，一个叫迈克尔·洪贝基（Michael Humbecky）的人，万一你认识他的话。然后我说，我得去取这张支票。他说，不行，你得开店。所以我做出了一个高层决定——去取支票。对。心想如果我递给他一张15,000美元的支票，
I got my $15,000 commission there, he'd be happy. Fires my ass. Wow. Fires me on the spot. And so that now I'm left with nothing. And I figured, OK, I'm a lousy employee. So I'm going to go start this company. I was in the PC business, so I called it micro-solutions
我拿到了我的15,000美元佣金，他会很高兴的。结果他把我给炒了。哇。当场把我开除了。所以现在我什么都没有了。我想，好吧，我真是个糟糕的员工。那我索性去创业吧。我当时在PC行业，所以我把它叫做微解法（micro-solutions）
and started with a first customer, $500, grew that to 80 employees, $30 some million in sales, and sold it to H&R Block. And was this based on something that you studied, did you study computers or business or anything? No, no, I like cheated in my computer class in Indiana. So who's yours, baby? Wait, say again, how old were you again?
从第一个客户500美元开始，发展到80名员工，3千万美元的销售额，并把它卖给了H&R Block。这跟你学的东西有关吗？你学的是计算机、商业还是别的什么？没有，没有，我在印第安纳的计算机课上作弊了。所以谁是你的，宝贝？等等，再说一遍，你当时多大？
I was 24. 24, and what age was that when you were like, wait a minute, this is kind of cool, I can buy and sell companies and all that? No, it's just like, I got fired, and it was like, I had to do something, I realized I was a bad employee, but in the nine months I was there, I learned a lot about software. And not a lot of people knew much about software.
我24岁。24岁，那你什么时候开始觉得，等一下，这挺酷的，我可以买卖公司以及诸如此类的？不，就是，我被解雇了，当时就像是，我必须做点什么，我意识到自己是个糟糕的员工，但在那呆的九个月里，我对软件了解了很多。当时没有多少人对软件了解很多。
So I was able to go company to company to company and just slowly but surely hired one person, then two person, then 10 till we get up to about 80 people. And then it took seven years without a vacation. So it wasn't like overnight, sold it, but a lifetime passed on American Airlines and partied like a rockstar. Oh my God.
所以我能够一家接一家地去到不同的公司，慢慢地、稳妥地先雇一个人，再雇两个人，然后是10个人，直到我们发展到大约80人。然后我花了七年时间没有休假。所以这不是那种一夜暴富、马上卖掉的情况，而是拿到了美国航空公司的终身通行证，像摇滚巨星一样狂欢。噢天哪。
And we will be right back. Smartlis is supported by NetSuite by Oracle. If your business earns millions or tens of millions of revenue, stop what you're doing and take a listen because NetSuite by Oracle is just rolled out the best offer we have ever seen. NetSuite gives you the visibility and control you need to make better decisions faster. And for the first time in NetSuite's 25 years as the number one cloud financial system, you can defer payments of a full NetSuite implementation for six months. There's no payment and no interest for six months. And you can take advantage of this special financing offer today. Net suite is number one because they give your business
我们马上回来。Smartless由甲骨文公司的NetSuite赞助。如果你的企业营业额达到数百万甚至数千万，停下你手中的活听一听，因为甲骨文公司的NetSuite刚刚推出了我们见过的最棒的优惠。NetSuite为你提供更好的决策和更快行动所需的洞察力和控制力。在NetSuite作为头号云财务系统的25年历史中，破天荒头一次，你可以推迟六个月支付完整的NetSuite实施费用。六个月内零付款、零利息。你今天就可以享受这个特别的融资优惠。NetSuite之所以排名第一，是因为它为你的企业
everything you need in real time all in one place to reduce manual processes, boost efficiency, build forecast and increase productivity across every department. It just sounds like it makes a lot of sense listener, right? I mean? You can agree with that, can't you? You're so agreeable. Thank you. More than 36,000 companies have already upgraded to NetSuite gaining visibility and control over their financials, inventory, HR, e-commerce, and more.
在一个地方实时提供你所需的一切，以减少人工流程、提高效率、建立预测并提升各个部门的生产力。听众朋友，这听起来很有道理，对吧？我是说？你也会赞同的，对吧？你真是太随和了。谢谢。已有超过36,000家公司升级使用了NetSuite，在财务、库存、人力资源、电子商务等方面获得了洞察力和控制力。
So if you've been sizing NetSuite up to make the switch, then you know this deal is unprecedented. No interest, no payments. Take advantage of this special financing offer at NetSuite Up to make the switch, then you know this deal is unprecedented. No interest, no payments. Take advantage of this special financing offer at netsuite.com slash smartless netsuite.com slash smartless to get the visibility and control you need to weather any storm netsuite.com slash smartless smartless smartless sponsored by ADT. ABT self setup features everything from motion sensors to Google Nest cams with no long-term contracts.
所以，如果你一直在考虑换用NetSuite，那你就会知道这个优惠是前所未有的。零利息，零付款。请立即在 netsuite.com/smartless 享受这一特别融资优惠，前往 netsuite.com/smartless 以获得应对任何风浪所需的洞察力和控制力，netsuite.com/smartless，smartless，smartless 由 ADT 赞助。ADT 自助安装系统提供从运动传感器到谷歌 Nest 摄像头的各种设备，且无长期合同。
Easy install the ADT self setup security system at your convenience. No heavy duty tools are needed. And if you need help, ADT can provide virtual assistance along the way. ADT self-startup grows, moves, and adapts as your needs change. You can add more products at any time and your system easily moves wherever life takes you. It also features nest cams that can tell the difference between a person, an animal, a vehicle, or with the Nest Doorbell even a package. Plus, when every second counts, you can trust ADT's 24-7 professional monitoring.
在您方便的时候轻松安装 ADT 自助安全系统。不需要重型工具。如果您需要帮助，ADT 可以一路提供虚拟协助。ADT 自助安装系统会随着您的需求变化而成长、移动和适应。您可以随时添加更多产品，并且无论生活带您去哪里，您的系统都可以轻松随行。它还配有 Nest 摄像头，能够区分人、动物、车辆，甚至使用 Nest 门铃识别包裹。此外，当每一秒都至关重要时，您可以信赖 ADT 的 24/7 专业监控。
You can view video of an alarm event and verify or cancel an alarm with just a tap. When the most trusted name and home security adds the intelligence of Google, you've got a home with no worries. So go to ADT.com today or call 1-800-ADT-ASAP, Google, Nest Cam, Nest Doorbell, and Nest Aware are trademarks of Google LLC. This episode is brought to you in part by 8 sleep. Hey, did you know that temperature is one of the most important factors in improving your sleep quality?
您只需轻轻一按，即可查看报警事件的视频并确认或取消报警。当家庭安全领域最值得信赖的名字融入谷歌的智能技术时，您就拥有了一个无忧无虑的家。因此，今天就访问 ADT.com 或致电 1-800-ADT-ASAP，Google、Nest Cam、Nest Doorbell 和 Nest Aware 是 Google LLC 的商标。本集部分内容由 Eight Sleep 赞助。嘿，你知道温度是改善睡眠质量最重要的因素之一吗？
Did you know that? Well, I'm going to fill you in here. While traditional mattresses trap heat throughout the night's science has shown that your body temperature actually needs to drop in the early and middle part of your sleep and rise in the morning so that you can fall asleep fast and get more deep sleep. The pod cover by eight sleep fits on any bed like a fitted sheet
你知道吗？好吧，我来告诉你。虽然传统床垫在整夜都会锁住热量，但科学表明，你的身体温度实际上需要在睡眠的早期和中期下降，并在早晨上升，这样你才能快速入睡并获得更多深度睡眠。Eight Sleep 的智能床罩（Pod Cover）像床单一样适用于任何床铺，
and will improve your sleep by automatically adjusting the temperature on each side of the bed based on you and your partner's individual needs. You know, me and my wife, we've got different needs and a lot of things in life, not the least of which is sleep temperature. You know, sometimes I'm all heated up about one thing and other times she's
并通过根据你和伴侣各自的需求自动调节床铺两侧的温度来改善你的睡眠。你知道的，我和我妻子在生活中的很多事情上都有不同的需求，其中最不重要的就是睡眠温度。你知道，有时我对某件事感到很激动，而有时她
well, you know, and I, it's just who falls asleep at the same temperature as your partner? You ever thought about that? Probably no one. So, you know, this is saving mankind, simply put. While temperature is the biggest game changer, the pod cover has other amazing features. Listen up, for example, thanks to the pod's sleep and health tracking, you can wake up to a personalized sleep report for you each morning that offers insights on how certain behaviors like late night exercise or caffeine impact your sleep and overall health.
嗯，你知道的，而且我，谁能和伴侣在相同的温度下入睡呢？你想过这个吗？可能没有人。所以，简而言之，这简直是在拯救人类。虽然温度是最关键的改变者，但这款床罩还有其他惊人的功能。听好了，例如，由于该床罩的睡眠和健康追踪功能，你每天早晨都可以醒来获得一份个性化的睡眠报告，其中提供了关于深夜锻炼或咖啡因等某些行为如何影响你的睡眠和整体健康的见解。
caffeine impact your sleep and overall health. So let's invest in the rest you deserve with the 8-Sleep Pod. Go to 8-Sleep.com slash smartless and save $150 on the pod cover by 8-Sleep. That's the best offer you'll find, but you must visit 8-Sleep.com slash smartless for $150 off. 8-Sleep currently ships within the USA, Canada, the UK select countries in the EU and Australia. And now back to the show. Would you say that the thing that is more important
咖啡因如何影响你的睡眠和整体健康。因此，让我们用 Eight Sleep Pod 投资于你应得的休息。访问 8-Sleep.com/smartless，购买 Eight Sleep 智能床罩即可省下 150 美元。这是你能找到的最佳优惠，但你必须访问 8-Sleep.com/smartless 才能立减 150 美元。Eight Sleep 目前在美國、加拿大、英國、歐盟部分國家和澳洲發貨。现在回到节目中。你会不会说，对于你的成功来说，更重要的是
to your success is your knowledge of the field or your ability to identify people that are good to work in other words, your people skills or your knowledge of your profession. I think it's that I really, I'm a quick learner, I'm a quick study, right? So when I go into new technologies, I can pick stuff up really fast. And so I'm able to, you say, okay, that's what's next. And so find an angle, what's coming next. Yeah, how do you know that?
是你对该领域的知识，还是你识别优秀人才的能力，换句话说，是你的为人处世能力还是你对本职的专业知识？我觉得是因为我真的是一个学得很快的人，我能快速掌握知识，对吧？所以当我接触新科技时，我能非常快地学会。因此我能够说，好的，接下来就是这个。从而找到一个切入点，看看接下来会发生什么。对，你是怎么知道的？
Like, to me it just makes sense. Like, you know, when I started microsolutions, instead of just buying one PC, I thought people are gonna connect them together. And most people are like, no, that's not to a later. And then they connect them together, that was my thing, and then wrote software for it, taught myself to write software and built it up.
对我来说这很简单。比如，当我创办微解法公司时，我没有只买一台电脑，而是认为人们会把它们连接在一起。大多数人觉得，不，那是很久以后的事了。然后他们把它们连在一起，这就是我的特色，然后我为此编写软件，自学编写软件并把它做大。
And then in the mid 90s, you know, a buddy of mine came to me and said, there's got to be a way we can listen to Indiana basketball over this new thing called the Internet. And I was like, okay, I'll figure it out. And then you created audio on the Internet. It was called audio net. It was the first streaming company on the Internet. And why? Because I'm very young. So the Internet didn't have audio at first and you kind of created that with this. No, people thought I was a moron.
然后在90年代中期，你知道，我的一个朋友来找我，说肯定有一种方法可以通过这个叫互联网的新东西来收听印第安纳大学的篮球赛。我说，好吧，我会弄明白的。然后你就创造了互联网音频。它叫AudioNet。它是互联网上第一家流媒体公司。为什么？因为我很年轻。所以互联网起初没有音频，而你是通过这个创造了它？不，人们觉得我是个白痴。
Yeah, there was like a player. I remember there was like an audio player that you had to have a play-out. Yeah, in order to stream back in the early days, right? You had to have a PC with a modem, download this thing called a TCP IP client, download a client software from your ISP, then download another real, an audio player, right?
对，当时有一个播放器。我记得有一个音频播放器，你必须得有个播放端。对，要在早期进行流媒体传输，对吧？你必须有一台电脑和一个调制解调器，下载一个叫 TCP IP 客户端的东西，从你的 ISP 下载客户端软件，然后下载另一个 Real 音频播放器，对吧？
And then you had to go to a website and click on a file, and that file would open up, and then you hope it would play. We had a half hour. But then you're all set. But then you're all set, right? But we were the first to do it. But like, one of our best, one of the things that helped us the most, like if you were anywhere outside the city of Chicago,
然后你必须访问一个网站并点击一个文件，那个文件就会打开，然后你祈祷它能播放。我们花了半个小时。但随后你就一切就绪了。但随后你就一切就绪了，对吧？但我们是第一家做这个的。不过，就像，我们最好的东西之一，对我们帮助最大的事情之一，如果你在芝加哥市以外的任何地方，
the only way to listen to the Cubs games during the afternoon was on audio and that right so we crushed it because Cubs fans all over the world would go there click on this thing and go through all the hassle you know but that started the whole streaming industry and then that just you know like so you're doing your crazy business did you have an idea when you were whatever 24 and back then that you did you have this dream? I'm gonna be a fucking business Titan. I'm gonna do this. Did you did that was that a possibility? No, no, you know like my doing micro solutions. I remember vividly Finally getting a bed laying there hung over gone. Oh my god. We've been in business three months
下午唯一能听小熊队比赛的地方就是在 AudioNet 上，对吧，所以我们太火了，因为全世界的小熊队球迷都会去那里，点击这个东西，经历所有的麻烦，你知道的，但这就开启了整个流媒体行业，然后这就，你知道的，所以你在做你疯狂的生意时，无论你当时24岁还是多大，你当时有这个梦想吗？我要成为他妈的商业巨头。我要大干一场。你有过这种可能性吗？不，不，你知道的，就像我做微解法时。我清晰地记得终于买了一张床，宿醉地躺在那里想，天哪。我们已经开业三个月了
Oh my god. We've been in business four months. Oh my God, we've been in business five months, right? Just being terrified that it went last. So it was just piece by piece that it just sort of... Just crying, you just crying, crying, crying. What are you gonna hope you would become? When did you study in school? I took a business, yeah. So you just hope to find a business,
天哪。我们已经开业四个月了。天哪，我们已经开业五个月了，对吧？只是害怕它无法持久。所以它是一步一步才变成……只是在哭，你就在哭，哭，哭。你希望自己成为什么样的人？你在学校里学的是什么？我学的是商业，对。所以你只是希望能开创一番事业，
didn't matter what it was. I knew I'd be an entrepreneur, right? Cause I'd start a business as my entire life little things. But where did that come from? Like, as a kid, where your parents run it? Like, see, I think what's fascinating about you and people like you is like, we're on the outside going, how do this guy do that?
不管它是什么。我知道我会成为一名企业家，对吧？因为我一整年都在做各种小生意。但这源于哪里？比如作为一个孩子，你的父母是经营什么的？看，我觉得关于你和像你这样的人，最迷人的是，我们在外面看着说，这家伙是怎么做到的？
Like, we're like, is there steps I could take to maybe be like Mark Cuban? Like, where did I fucking go wrong? You know what I mean? Yeah, I mean. I could tell you. I mean, opening with a masturbation story. I also wanna know, like, what is that moment?
就像我们在想，有没有什么步骤我可以遵循，也许能成为马克·库班？我到底他妈的哪里做错了？你知道我的意思吗？对，我是说。我可以告诉你。我是说，以一个手淫的故事开场。我还想知道，那一刻是什么？
Do you, you probably do, and tell us if you do. Remember the moment that you were, you first realized, or the moment you were first, a billionaire. Well, fuck yeah, a remover. So, yeah, so. I was like, that insects for the first time, right? Yeah, yeah.
你，你可能记得，如果你记得的话就告诉我们。还记得你第一次意识到，或者你第一次成为亿万富翁的那一刻。哦，他妈的当然记得，我忘不了。所以，对。就像第一次看到昆虫那样，对吧？对，对。
You remember it every bit of it. All time, right? Yeah, yeah. You remember every bit of it. All right, Sean? Yes, Sean. No, because broadcast.com went public. And we had this big IPO, and the stock just kept on going up. And I knew exactly what the price had to be in order for me to become a billionaire. And so on the OPCs, you get it F5 to refresh your Yahoo Finance.
你每个细节都记得。总是这样，对吧？对，对。你每一个细节都记得。对吧，肖恩？是的，肖恩。不，因为 broadcast.com 上市了。我们有了一次盛大的首次公开募股（IPO），股票一直在涨。我清楚地知道股价必须达到多少我才能成为亿万富翁。所以在个人电脑上，你不停按F5刷新雅虎财经。
You know, left five, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, and then, and it was like right when the market opened in Dallas at 830. And so I'm just sitting there basically mostly naked and I didn't live at home, right by myself. Getting that F5. Yeah. But that's, you're just by yourself at home when you're fucking home computer going,
你知道的，F5，轰，轰，轰，轰，轰，轰，轰，轰，轰，轰，轰，轰，轰，轰，轰，轰，然后，就在达拉斯市场早上8:30开盘的时候。所以我基本上光着身子坐在那儿，我没有住在家里的，就我自己一个人。狂按 F5。对。但那是，你一个人独自在家，在你的破电脑前想着，
am I a billionaire? Yes, and then I do my little billionaire dance, right? I was just like, hey! Would you, would you do to get what you call first? No, what's that? Did you call? No, because I knew, you know, it might only be a second, right? Right, right, right.
我是亿万富翁了吗？是的，然后我跳了我那支小小的亿万富翁舞，对吧？我当时就像是，嘿！你会，你会做什么来庆祝？不，那是什么？你庆祝了吗？不，因为我知道，（成为亿万富翁的时刻）可能只持续一秒钟，对吧？对，对，对。
Just like Sean's story. Oh my god. Sean. That's good. What my God. Sean. That's good. What do you guys do this? Yeah, OK, great. Well, I think everybody here has had the fantasy of like,
就像肖恩的故事。哦天哪。肖恩。这很好。我的天哪。肖恩。这很好。你们俩为什么要做这个？对，好吧，太棒了。嗯，我想这里的每个人都曾幻想过，
what if I won the lottery? If I became, what's my fantasy big thing to buy? What was it? Basketball team. Yeah, there you go. Was it really? Yeah. There we go. Was it really? It wasn't like I dreamed about it.
如果我中彩票了会怎样？如果我成为了，我最想买的大件是什么？那是什么？篮球队。耶，这不就对了。真的是这样吗？对。我们走。真的是这样吗？这倒不是我梦寐以求的。
But I mean, what was the first big check? Maybe it was 20 grand or 100 grand or something. Well, when I saw my first company, Micro Solutions, I literally, my buddies and I went out and just got shit-faced at an old school Italian restaurant. They had the phones that they would bring to you. And so I was trash. And they're like, what do you want? I'm like not into cars, not into, I have a house.
但我是说，第一张大支票是多少？也许是两万美元或十万美元之类的。好吧，当我卖掉我的第一家公司“微解法”时，说实话，我和我的好哥们去了一家老派意大利餐厅喝得烂醉。他们有那种可以拿给你的电话。所以我当时喝瘫了。他们问：“你想要什么？”我说我对车不感兴趣，对房子不感兴趣，
I want a lifetime pass in American Airlines. So I can just go anywhere, anytime, anyhow. Really? And so I traveled enough that I remember the number and I'd call them up and I'm like, do you guys sell lifetime passes? And they were like, yes, let me connect you to the Air Pass Department.
我想要一张美国航空公司的终身通行证。这样我就可以随时随地去任何我想去的地方。真的吗？所以我飞得够多，我记住了那个号码，我打电话过去问：“你们卖终身通行证吗？”他们回答说：“是的，我帮你转接空中通行证部门。”
I'm like, get the fuck out of here, right? And I bought one and it ended up being $250,000, and I got to fly me and anybody else that I wanted, anywhere American Airlines flies for the rest of my life. As often as you want. As often as I want. No way. Wait, just for a flat.
我说：“滚开吧你！”对吧？然后我买了一张，最后花了25万美元，这让我和任何我想带的人，在我的余生里都可以飞往美国航空公司飞往的任何地方。只要你想去。只要我想去。绝不可能。等等，就只需一次性支付。
I gave it to my dad who unfortunately passed away a few years ago, and then I gave it to a friend who uses it So it was a $250,000 flat fee no more money ever for the rest of your life And you can fly you plus one anywhere you want all the time you want until you first class They still have no way they still have that no they got rid of them because there were a couple guys You could spend that in that yeah, I also got my American Airlines miles, right? So there'd be guys you just fly back and forth just to get their miles, and that was just like, too much.
我把它给了我父亲，他不幸于几年前去世了，后来我又把它给了一个经常使用它的朋友。所以这是一笔25万美元的一次性费用，余生再也不需要花一分钱，你可以带着你和一个同伴随时去任何你想去的地方，直到你头等舱……他们现在还有吗？不可能，他们现在还有这个吗？不，他们取消了，因为有几个家伙……你可以用它来……对。我还积攒了美国航空公司的里程，对吧？所以有些家伙会为了刷里程而飞来飞去，这简直是太夸张了。
Wow. But it was a lot of fun. Yeah. Where did you go to the Olympics? Let's go to Moscow. Let's go to Vegas. As long as you got delays and you got peanuts and the thing. Oh, great.
哇。但真的很有趣。对。你去过奥运会吗？去莫斯科吧。去拉斯维加斯吧。只要你有延误，有花生和那个东西。哦，太棒了。
We're going to find the thing that's a bummer about it. Where did, at what point did you want to go into a filmmaking television stuff and start your studio? That was more because of my partner Todd. Todd and I were partners for Todd Wanger and I were partners in broadcast.com. And he wanted to do a lot of vertically integrated stuff. And so after I sold broadcast, we also started the first all high definition TV network HD net.
我们要找出让人扫兴的地方。你在哪个时间点想要涉足电影电视制作并创立自己的工作室？这更多是因为我的合伙人托德。托德和我曾是 broadcast.com 的合伙人，托德·旺格（Todd Wanger）和我。他想做很多垂直整合的东西。所以在卖掉 broadcast 后，我们还创办了第一个全高清电视网络 HDNet。
And so, and then we bought landmark theaters. So, I started, we started HD net and we wanted to do day and day to everything, right? And this was, what is it? Day and day meeting, we released a movie on HD net and in theaters and landmark theaters and we released the DVD and we released it online. Oh, at the same time. Right. Right.
然后，我们收购了陆标剧院（Landmark Theaters）。所以，我创立了，我们创立了 HDNet，我们想做同步发行（day-and-date）的一切，对吧？这是，什么是？同步发行是指我们在 HDNet 上、在剧院、在陆标剧院发行电影，同时我们还发行 DVD，并且在网上发行。哦，同时进行。对。对。
Which now is a big deal, right? That they're trying to do with HBO Max. And so we started doing that. And probably 2003. We started doing little things. In 2003, I get an email from a guy named Alex Gibney. And he's like, I've got this footage from this company called Enron. And I email him back.
这现在可是件大事了，对吧？他们正试图在 HBO Max 上这样做。所以我们开始那样做。大概在2003年。我们开始做一些小事情。2003年，我收到了一封来自一个叫亚历克斯·吉布尼（Alex Gibney）的人的电子邮件。他说：“我这里有一家叫安然（Enron）的公司的素材。”我回信给他。
Oh, yeah, yeah. And I'm like, do you own the exclusive rights to it? Yeah. Can you put it in a move in your documentary you want to do? Yeah. What's the budget for this movie Enron that you want to do? And he goes $70,000 or $70,000. I'm like, OK, let's do it.
哦，对，对。我说：“你拥有它的独家版权吗？”“是的。”“你能把它放进你想拍的电影、你的纪录片里吗？”“是的。”“你这个想拍的关于安然的电影预算是多少？”他说：“7万美元，或者说7万美元。”我说：“好吧，我们干吧。”
12 minutes, I greenlit this movie. Yeah. So it turns out being Enron the smartest guys in the room, a documentary right? Yeah,000. I'm like, okay, let's do it. 12 minutes, I agree, let this movie. So it turns out being Enron the smartest guys in the room at Documentary Rights. It gets nominated for an Academy Award. At the time, it was top 10 grossing documentary of all time. I'm thinking this movie shit is easy, right?
12分钟内，我批准了这部电影。对。结果它成了纪录片《安然：房间里最聪明的人》（Enron: The Smartest Guys in the Room），对吧？7万美元。我说，好吧，干吧。12分钟内，我批准了这部电影。结果它成了纪录片《安然：房间里最聪明的人》的版权所有者。它获得了奥斯卡金像奖提名。当时，它是史上票房前十的纪录片。我心想，拍电影这事儿挺容易的嘛，对吧？
Then... Yeah, this isn't gonna be a money pit at all. No, at all, right? Then my partner Todd Wagner brings to me a deal with George Clooney. It's going to be a black and white movie about the 50s with Roy Cohen and the McCarthy hearings, right? Good luck with that guy. Right, and it was going to be called Good Night and Good Luck.
然后……对，这绝不会是个无底洞。不，一点也不，对吧？然后我的合伙人托德·旺格给我带来了一笔与乔治·克鲁尼合作的交易。这将是一部关于50年代的黑白电影，讲的是罗伊·科恩（Roy Cohen）和麦卡锡听证会的故事，对吧？祝那家伙好运吧。对，这部电影将被称为《晚安，好运》（Good Night, and Good Luck）。
Yeah, such a good movie. Such a good movie. Such a good, it gets nominated for Six Academy Awards. My second movie on the, there's shit that's still easy, right? And even better yet, we had, because we got nominated, we had a party at, oh, what's the place on Hollywood? Anyways, one of the old school Italian restaurants. Dentanos. Dentanos. Yeah, right? And I'm doing a body shot off of Cindy Crawford.
对，多棒的一部电影。多棒的一部电影。多棒的一部，它获得了六项奥斯卡奖提名。这是我在电影界拍的第二部电影，拍电影这事儿确实挺容易的，对吧？更棒的是，因为我们获得了提名，我们在好莱坞的一个地方举办了派对，哦，叫什么来着？总之，是一家老牌意大利餐厅。丹塔诺斯（Dentanos）。丹塔诺斯。对吧？我正从辛迪·克劳馥身上做一个人体射击。
And I'm there going, shot off of Cindy Crawford. And I'm there going, this movie shit's great. This movie shit's great. You haven't heard of a movie we've done since, right? Right. We've done little things. We have a company. We sold, 29.29 still does some stuff.
我在那儿想着，从辛迪·克劳馥身上做射击。我在那儿想着，拍电影这事儿太棒了。拍电影这事儿太棒了。从那以后，你们就没听过我们拍过什么电影了，对吧？对。我们做了一些小事情。我们有一家公司。我们卖掉了，2929 Productions 仍然在做一些事情。
And we sold some of the other stuff. And we sold landmark theaters. And we still have magnolia pictures to distribute stuff. Yeah, let me do great, tell me something that you thought for sure was going to succeed and you're like, oh God, that did not work at all. Nothing. No.
我们卖掉了一些其他的东西。我们卖掉了陆标剧院。我们仍然拥有木兰影业（Magnolia Pictures）来发行东西。对，让我干得很好，告诉我一件事，你原以为一定会成功，结果却心想，天哪，这根本行不通。没有。不。
Wow. Excellent. Really? No, so many things. Like what's the biggest mistake you made early on in your career that you would like, the biggest thing you would give advice to somebody would like, watch out for this.
哇。太棒了。真的吗？没有，有很多事情。比如你在职业生涯早期犯过的最大错误是什么，你会给别人什么建议，比如提防这个。
I know you're doing great here, but really watch out for this person or this thing or this idea. Yeah, I think, you know, one of the lessons I learned is I would just hire fast, right? Because I'm a sales person at heart. And I would just like, okay, I'm selling myself on hiring this person.
我知道你现在干得很好，但真的要提防这个人、这件事或这个想法。对，我想，我学到的教训之一就是我雇人太快了，对吧？因为我本质上是个销售人员。我总是会说，好吧，我在说服自己雇佣这个人。
And I've learned you got a higher slow in fire fast. So I would make a lot of mistakes in hiring that cost me money. Why? Because just you interview too many people who really want to find out the right fit? Yeah, where I would not interview enough. Right. And so I would just be like, OK, come on, I'll make it work.
我学到的是，你必须慢招人、快炒人。所以我会在招聘上犯很多错误，让我花了很多钱。为什么？因为你面试的人太少，没有真正找到合适的人吗？对，我面试的人不够多。所以我就会想，好吧，来吧，我会让它运转起来的。
I would be so good person. Yeah, yeah. I would be so arrogant that I thought, OK, I can make this work no matter what. Or I'd be so arrogant about how much business I know. I look at a business and go, OK, you're going to do this wrong, this wrong, this wrong. And yeah, I know Uber is going to be good.
我会成为一个好人。对，对。我会狂妄自大到以为，好吧，不管怎样我都能把这事儿搞定。或者我对自己的商业知识过于傲慢。我看着一家生意心想，好吧，你这里做错了，那里做错了，错在这儿，错在那儿。是的，我知道优步（Uber）会很棒。
And I know you're going gonna do really well with Uber, but you need to give me a better valuation. And the guy's like, no. And so I missed out on Uber, you know? What do you think is your, seems like you've really checked a lot of boxes and had a lot of success, you're not an old guy. Like what are you thinking about would be
我知道你在优步上会干得非常好，但你需要给我一个更好的估值。而那家伙说，不。所以我错过了优步，你知道吗？你觉得你，看来你确实达成了很多成就，也取得了巨大的成功，你并不是个老头子。那你觉得接下来会对你构成
a really significant challenge for you that actually scares you going forward? Well like right now we're taking on the pharmacy companies. Yes, I was gonna ask you about this. Yeah This is Do you guys not have you heard about what he's doing? I haven't told me it's amazing. So it's called cost plus Plus so Cost plus drugs.
真正重大挑战、甚至让你感到害怕的事情是什么？嗯，就像现在我们正在挑战制药公司。是的，我正要问你这个。对，这是……你们没听说他在做什么吗？我不知道，快告诉我，这太神奇了。它叫平价加价（Cost Plus）
Drugs.com. And so basically what we've done, the pharmacy industry is really distorted. They have these things called pharmacy benefit managers that are kind of like bouncers at clubs. They want to get paid in order for the pharmaceutical companies to provide their drugs to insurance companies who then approve them for doctors.
加价。Drugs.com。基本上我们所做的是，医药行业真的被严重扭曲了。他们有被称为药品福利管理机构（PBM）的东西，有点像俱乐部的保镖。他们想要获得报酬，以便制药公司将他们的药物提供给保险公司，然后由保险公司批准给医生。
And so we said, we're going to create our own pharmacy benefit manager, but we're not going to make it convoluted. We're not going to ask for rebates like all the other ones do. Because of that, we can sell direct to consumers at our cost plus 15%. Give us an example of... I can't even pronounce all of these, but it will take something...
所以我们说，我们要创建自己的药品福利管理机构，但我们不会把它搞得错综复杂。我们不会像其他机构那样索要回扣。正因为如此，我们可以按成本加成15%直接向消费者销售。给我们举个例子……我甚至念不出所有这些药的名字，但随便拿一种……
Insulin, yeah. No, we don't have insulin yet. We're working on the outskirts. Take that back. Yeah. Yeah. We're working on the LK. Take that back. Yeah. Yeah. We're working on it. But if you go to CosplusDrucks.com,
胰岛素，对。不，我们还没有胰岛素。我们正在外围努力。收回刚才的话。对。对。我们正在努力。收回刚才的话。对。对。我们正在努力。但如果你去 CostPlusDrugs.com，
you can see exactly what our cost are. And so there's drugs that will sell for $6 that everybody else is selling for $400. That's amazing. How is it? And when do you think? I just think that's incredible. CosplusDrucks.com.
你可以准确看到我们的成本是多少。有些药我们只卖6美元，而其他人都在卖400美元。这太惊人了。怎么会这样？你觉得什么时候……我觉得这太不可思议了。CostPlusDrugs.com。
Now, are you doing this now? Is this a business for you? Is there a profit in here for you somewhere? So everything we're transparent about everything. So we're not trying to make as much money as possible. It's a public benefit corporation, so it's different in what we're allowed to do, too. But we reinvest, so the market of 15%,
现在，你是在做这个吗？这对你来说是一项业务吗？这里面有你的利润吗？所以我们对一切都是透明的。我们并不是为了赚尽可能多的钱。它是一家公益公司，所以在我们被允许做的事情上也不同。但我们会进行再投资，所以15%的市场利润，
we reinvest so that we're building a manufacturing facility in Dallas so we can push down the price of drugs. So our goal, we're starting off with 100 drugs two weeks ago and our goal by the end of the year is to have 2,000 drugs and our bigger goal is, now we're so used to seeing prices of drugs who will up, up, up, up, up, right? Every week or two, we wanna be able to post
我们将其再投资，以便在达拉斯建立一个制造厂，这样我们就可以把药价压下去。所以我们的目标是，两周前我们从100种药物开始，我们到年底的目标是拥有2,000种药物，而我们更大的目标是，现在我们已经习惯了看到药价不断往上涨，对吧？每隔一两周，我们就能公布
a reduction in price of the drugs that we have, right? How are you able to access these drugs at a wholesale price, though? Because we go right to the main factories. Just asking again, because they didn't hear. Oh, sorry, how are you able to access these drugs at a wholesale price, though? Because we go right to the main factories. What were the factories asking again, because they didn't hear it. Oh, sorry. How are you able to access these drugs at a wholesale price? We'll go to the manufacturers or we'll make them ourselves. And the ones we go to the manufacturers, they have to sell them basically, you know, just
我们拥有的药物价格下降的消息，对吧？不过，你们是怎么能以批发价买到这些药的呢？因为我们直接去找主要工厂。再问一遍，因为他们没听到。哦，抱歉，你们是怎么能以批发价买到这些药的呢？因为我们直接去找主要的工厂。工厂里的人要求……再问一遍，因为他们没听到。哦，抱歉。你们是怎么能以批发价买到这些药的呢？我们会去找制造商，或者我们自己制造。至于那些我们去找制造商的药，他们基本上必须以……
a little bit more than they sell to everybody else. Yeah. But everybody else asks for rebates from them, which in turn, jacks up the price. We don't ask for any of those rebates. We don't fuck around with the price. It is just cost plus 15%. $3 filfee and $5 for shipping. Well, if you guys thought about making
比卖给其他所有人稍微贵一点的价格出售。对。但其他人会向他们索要回扣，这反过来推高了价格。我们不索要任何这些回扣。我们不会在价格上搞鬼。这就是成本加上15%。3美元的配药费和5美元的运费。好吧，你们有没有想过制造
any of the fun drugs? Yeah. I mean, you just like a whole fun page. You don't even mean over like... Yeah, you just put a slash molly and I'm not saying it. Well, you, my husband, Scottie, he's got diabetes since he's 17 years old. It's hilarious.
任何有趣（娱乐性）的药物？对。我是说，你就像一个充满趣味的网页。你甚至不用……对，你只要加个斜杠 molly（摇头丸），我不是那个意思。好吧，你，我的丈夫斯科蒂（Scottie），他从17岁起就患有糖尿病。这太滑稽了。
But I, whenever I introduce him, I go, this is my husband, Scottie, he's gonna die from diabetes. No, will that be on that list, insulin or...? So, to do insulin, it's this all convoluted thing where you've got to create something called a biosimilar. So it's a mess. It's hard. And so we're looking at it, but it takes close to four years. And so we're looking at starting that process.
但每次我介绍他时，我都会说，这是我丈夫斯科蒂，他将死于糖尿病。不，这会在这份名单上吗，胰岛素还是……？所以，要生产胰岛素，这是一个非常复杂的过程，你必须制造一种叫做生物仿制药（biosimilar）的东西。所以这是一团糟。这很难。因此我们在研究它，但这需要近四年时间。所以我们正在考虑开始这个过程。
And what are some of the, how do you determine what companies you want to invest in or where you want to put your money? You know, it really depends. Like on Shark Tank, Friday nights on ABC, APM, BST, or SMPM Central. Yeah, I can't wait to get it right into it
那么其中一些，你是如何决定你想投资哪些公司，或者你想把钱投在哪里的？你知道，这真的取决于情况。就像在《创智赢家》（Shark Tank）上，每周五晚在 ABC 播出，晚上8点东部/太平洋时间，或者晚上7点中部时间。是的，我已经迫不及待想加入进去了
no shark tank is part t v right so you're not making normal business decisions but normally it's like is it differentiated you know is there a reason for me to buy it like we started cost plus drugs dot com there's no marketing we're not spending any money on on marketing or advertising because everybody wants cheaper prices for drugs Yeah, right? And so it really depends on what the product is and if there's if it's differentiated
不，《创智赢家》是一档电视节目，对吧？所以你不是在做常规的商业决策，但通常它是这样的：它是有差异化的吗？我有什么理由去买它？就像我们创办 CostPlusDrugs.com 一样，没有市场营销，我们在营销或广告上不花任何钱，因为每个人都想要更便宜的药品价格。
It's something people obviously need and the person who creates it is Smart then I typically try to invest so you're talking to a dumbass, right guys Confirmed confirmed so right guys. Confirmed? Confirmed. So, somebody comes on Shark Tank. What they do is they pitch you an idea and you decide whether that's a great idea and if it's a better idea than the other two people that pitched, they get what? Funding for their idea? Yeah. Yeah, I'm so sorry man. Yeah. You never watch the show, Ed. I I watched Dodgers and that's it. That's okay. Now, do you obviously own a piece of that company if it takes off?
对吧？所以这真的取决于产品是什么，它是否有差异化，它是人们明显需要的东西，而且创造它的人很聪明，那么我通常会尝试投资。所以你在和一个笨蛋说话，对吧，伙计们？已确认，已确认。所以，有人来到《创智赢家》。他们做的是向你推销一个创意，然后你决定这是否是一个好创意，如果它比另外两个人的创意更好，他们会得到什么？为他们的创意提供资金？对。对，我很抱歉，伙计。对。你从不看这个节目，埃德。我只看道奇队的比赛，就这样。没关系。现在，如果公司起飞了，你显然拥有该公司的一部分股份吗？
Well, if I invest in money, yes, I ask for a piece of the company. Yeah, I do. You own the whole thing? My God. Or like what's never won on the old whole thing? Because you want the entrepreneur, the person who started it, right to be successful and make money too. What's the percentage that they get?
如果我投资了资金，是的，我会要求获得公司的一部分股份。是的，我确实如此。你拥有全部吗？天哪。或者像什么……从来没赢过整个公司吧？因为你希望企业家、那个创办它的人也能成功并赚到钱。他们能得到多少股份？
Typically, they'll keep 80% of it now. I'll just take care of it now just take a look at what's dark tank the rest of you believe it's right i have a miss so so wait let's get right into it because i've eight hundred questions okay wait a minute just hang on let's say all right so should we have commercial commercial wait uh... okay so the same question about your business.
通常，他们现在会保留80%的股份。我现在就接管它，现在只要看看剩下的你们谁相信《创智赢家》是真的……我有一个失误，所以——所以等等，让我们直接切入正题，因为我有800个问题。好吧，等等，稍等一下。让我们说，好吧，我们该做广告了吗？广告，等等，呃……好吧，关于你的生意，有个同样的问题。
What is the criteria you look for on Shark Tank when somebody comes in and pitches something? What is it? Spiked ball. That's the one I fucked up on. Thank you very much. What is it? No, spike ball.
当有人进来推销某个东西时，你在《创智赢家》中寻找的标准是什么？是什么？Spikeball（圆网球）。那就是我搞砸的那个。非常感谢。是什么？不，Spikeball。
Spiked ball. Have you ever seen kids on the beach playing? Yes, yes, right. So they came on Shark Tank and they're like, Mark, we want you to be an investor. They want you, they want me to be the commissioner of their spikeball league. I'm like, I don't want to be a commissioner of the spikeball league. Yeah.
Spikeball。你见过海滩上的小孩子们在玩吗？是的，是的，对。所以他们来到《创智赢家》说，马克，我们想让你成为投资者。他们想要你，他们想让我成为他们的 Spikeball 联赛的总裁。我说，我才不想当什么 Spikeball 联赛的总裁呢。对吧？
You know, so I didn't do the deal. Now every beach, everywhere. You go, you know, down here on the beach. And that's all you see anywhere. What spikeball is that like volleyball? Guys, I don't fucking know it. Guys, I don't fucking do it. They're fucking building you, dude. I don't know what it is either.
你知道的，所以我没有做这笔交易。现在到处都是海滩。你走过去，你知道，就在这里的海滩上。你到处都能看到这个。Spikeball 是什么，像排球吗？伙计们，我他妈的不知道。伙计们，我他妈的没玩过。他们在坑你呢，老兄。我也不知道那是什么。
Black boys, they have like this little trampoline. There's little trampoline thing. You stand around with some friends and you hit this ball and you bounce it off the thing, right? Oh, never mind. And you all bounce off. And just very kind of competitive and it's good exercise. And you get it up. I didn't need you to get it up.
黑男孩，他们有那种小蹦床。有个小蹦床一样的东西。你和一些朋友站在周围，击打这个球，把它从那个东西上弹开，对吧？哦，没关系。然后你们一起弹开。这非常有竞技性，而且是个很好的锻炼。你能把它弄起来。我不需要你把它弄起来。
Yeah. That sounds fun. But I wouldn't hear that idea and go, that's a billion dollar idea. Well, I knew kids would like it, right? But sometimes you just want to just invest. You don't want to be the commissioner. Right.
对。听起来挺好玩的。但我不会听到这个主意就觉得，这是一个价值十亿美元的主意。好吧，我知道孩子们会喜欢它，对吧？但有时你只是想投资。你不想当什么总裁。对吧？
You know, and so. So that was a part of the deal. That was part of the deal. Yeah, and I don't want to do that part of it. Yeah, you're busy. I'm busy. Yeah, so but do you have a, do you have a, like anytime you, you, you join a company or invest in a company office
你知道的，所以。这就是交易的一部分。那是交易的一部分。对，我不想做那部分。对，你很忙。我很忙。对，但是你有没有，你有没有，就像无论何时你加入一家公司或投资一家公司，通过
shark tank, do you have then a company yourself, like the people working a office somewhere that handles that? We used to work in an office now, but yeah, I have people who help me. Yeah, and so do you? Yeah, he's got a staff, Sean. You got a staff, Sean. I think he does it all himself.
《创智赢家》，你随后自己有一家公司吗，比如在某个地方有办公室里的人在处理这些？我们以前在办公室工作，但现在，是的，我有帮手。是的，你也有吗？对，他有团队，肖恩。你有个团队，肖恩。我觉得他都是自己一个人搞定的。
No, but, but. And I was going to make another joke for your first of an obnoxious. But I'm not going to. Fine. Wait, so, but when you, it has, is there, has there ever been a time when the cameras are over and they walk out and they're like,
不，但是，但是。我本想再开个玩笑说你第一反应很讨厌。但我不会的。好吧。等等，所以，但是当你，有没有，有没有过这样的时候，当摄像机停止拍摄，他们走出去，然后他们心想，
oh my god, I made a deal with Mark Cuban and you're done taping the show and then you and the deal falls through. Oh yeah, yeah. When do I use that? So sometimes they'll just lie their asses off, right? Because they get nervous, right? They may take. They lie, right?
哦天哪，我和马克·库班达成了一笔交易，然后你结束了节目的录制，接着你和这笔交易就黄了？哦，对，对。我什么时候用那个？所以有时他们会满嘴跑火车，对吧？因为他们很紧张，对吧？他们可能会接受。他们在说谎，对吧？
You know, I've got $1 million in sales and then you go, we get to do due diligence afterwards because we know people might not quite tell the truth. And then you go to look and they have 100,000 in sales, or 20,000 in sales, and they hope to have a million. You know, where my widget costs a dollar and it costs $10. So yeah, there's times when it doesn't close. Do you mind if I pitch you a product right now?
你知道的，我有一百万美元的销售额，然后你去了，我们要在事后进行尽职调查，因为我们知道人们可能不会完全说实话。然后你去一看，他们只有十万美元的销售额，或者两万美元的销售额，而他们只是希望有一百万。你知道的，我的小部件成本是一美元，售价却是十美元。所以是的，有时候交易就是无法达成。你介意我现在向你推销一个产品吗？
Let's go. Okay. All right. All right. Do you want to do it? Do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we,
我们开始吧。好的。好的。你想这么做吗？我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们。
do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do we, do Do will you get up there come on do will and I get us get I'm gonna do it actually I'm gonna bring out my husband Scotty so I do it in the truth fashion Stand up he's gonna be dead soon Yeah, come closer. Don't get too attached to him. I know. I'm going to die from diabetes. Yeah. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. All right, so here we go. Do you guys believe in Scotty's here?
我们要，我们要，我们要……（重复）好吧，你要上去了，来吧。好吧，威爾和我上去——我要上去了，其实我要把我老公斯科蒂（Scotty）请出来，所以我要以真实的方式来做。站起来，他快要死了。耶，过来。别对他产生太深厚的感情。我知道。我会死于糖尿病的。耶。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。好吧，那么我们开始吧。你们相信斯科蒂在这里吗？
Woo! Oh, my God. OK. OK, so this isn't the true style of Shark Tank. Wait, I thought you were pitching to me. Get your ass over there. I can't because then they'll say you're actually OK. Wait, I thought you're pitching to me. Get your ass over there. I can't because then they'll see you're actually okay. Oh, man, you're gonna be okay.
哇！哦，天哪。好吧。好吧，这可不是《创智赢家》（Shark Tank）的真实风格。等等，我以为你在向我推销呢。快把你的屁股挪到那边去。我不能，因为那样他们就会说你其实挺好的。等等，我以为你在向我推销呢。快把你的屁股挪到那边去。我不能，因为那样他们就会看到你其实挺好的。哦，天哪，你会没事的。
So here we go. Oh, okay. Oh, okay. Oh, okay. Oh, okay. Okay, shh. Shh, shh, shh. Shut the fuck up. Shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, sh, shh, sh, sh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, sh, shh, shh, shh And we're from Hollywood, California.
那我们开始吧。哦，好吧。哦，好吧。哦，好吧。哦，好吧。好吧，嘘。嘘，嘘，嘘。他妈的闭嘴。嘘……（重复）我们来自加利福尼亚州好莱坞。
And we're looking for $2 million for 2% of our company, Doggy Defense. When you're loading the dishwasher, does your dog come out and clean the plates before the dishwasher does? R's does, which gives us pause for concern. Oh, God. Oh, boy. Let me tell you a little tale. We came up with a fence barrier that goes around your dishwasher door
我们想为我们的公司“狗狗防御”（Doggy Defense）融资 200 万美元，换取 2% 的股份。当你把碗盘放进洗碗机时，你的狗狗会不会跑出来，在洗碗机开洗之前就把盘子舔干净？我们的狗会，这让我们不得不深思。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。让我给你们讲个小故事。我们想出了一种栅栏屏障，可以装在你的洗碗机门周围，
that detours your dog from accessing the dishes. And with that defense up, our dog is no longer barking up the wrong tree. So sharks, don't leave your dishes in a rough state. Who wants to be the first one to join our pack? Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Okay.
能阻止你的狗狗接触到盘子。有了这个防线，我们的狗就不会再无端狂吠了。所以各位鲨鱼们，别把你们的盘子留在那种乱糟糟的状态。谁想成为加入我们团队的第一个人？哦！哦！哦！哦！哦！好吧。
Shhh! Yeah. Now for the uninitiated, was that similar to the way it goes down? Oh, yeah! Yeah. Otherwise, that was really weird. No, no! No, no. You got to go.
嘘！耶。对于外行人来说，这和节目里的实际流程差不多吗？哦，耶！耶。不然的话，那就太诡异了。不，不！不，不。你得走了。
You got to go. The people that come on, God bless them, they're all lovely. They're all trying hard. They're really awkward and weird. They don't know how to, you know, they're obviously being coached and written and it's very practice. When is there a, where's the swimming part? When do you get in the water?
你得走了。那些上节目的嘉宾，上帝保佑他们，他们都挺可爱的。他们都在努力。他们真的很尴尬、很怪异。他们不知道怎么……你知道的，他们显然接受过培训和排练，而且非常熟练。游泳环节在什么时候？什么时候下水？
Right at the beginning, right? I want to hear what you think of the idea. Knowing that sound. Yeah. $6 million. I'm saying, you right? I want to hear what you think of the idea. What do you think of the idea? $200. I'm saying, right? So when you're at US dollars, hey, so when you pull the dishwasher down and you're doing it,
就在一开始，对吧？我想听听你对这个创意的看法。听到那个声音。耶。600 万美元。我说，对吗？我想听听你对这个创意的看法。你觉得这个创意怎么样？200 美元。我说，对吧？所以当你在用美元的时候，嘿，所以当你把洗碗机拉下来并这样做的时候，
and the don't touch the shots, yeah, we get it. I got it. I got it. OK. I thought I'd get it. I think it's a perfect deal for Mr. Wonderful. OK. No ask for royalty.
还有别碰那些镜头，对，我们懂了。我懂了。我懂了。好吧。我还以为我会懂呢。我觉得这对“美好先生”（Mr. Wonderful）来说是一笔完美的交易。好吧。不要求特许权使用费。
Yeah, royalty. I love it. I just wanted to hear you once say, I'm out. but I think it's a perfect deal for Mr. Wonderful. Oh, okay. No ask for royalty. Yeah, royalty. I love it. I just wanted to hear you once say, I'm out. That's right. Oh. We'll be right back. SmartLess is supported by Rocket Money. Now, this company seems to make a whole lot of sense to me.
对，特许权使用费。我喜欢。我只是想听你说一次：“我出局了。”但我觉得这对“美好先生”来说是一笔完美的交易。哦，好吧。不要求特许权使用费。对，特许权使用费。我喜欢。我只是想听你说一次：“我出局了。”没错。哦。我们马上回来。SmartLess 得到了 Rocket Money 的支持。现在，这家公司对我们来说似乎非常有意义。
So most people think they're spending $80 on the subscriptions when in reality the number is closer to 200. When you're signed up for so many things like streaming services you use to watch one show or free trials for delivery, you don't use, it's so easy to lose track of what you're paying for. With rocket money, you can easily cancel the ones you don't want with just the press of one button. No more long hold times or annoying emails with customer service.
所以大多数人认为他们在订阅上花 了 80 美元，但实际上这个数字接近 200 美元。当你注册了那么多服务，比如只为了看一部剧而购买的流媒体服务，或者你根本不用的免费配送试用，你很容易忘记你到底在为什么付钱。有了 Rocket Money，只需按一下按钮，你就可以轻松取消那些你不需要的服务。
Rocket money does all the work for you. Rocket money can even negotiate to lower your bills for you. Yeah, buy up to like 20%. All you have to do is take a picture of your bill and rocket money takes care of the rest. I mean, does that not make sense? Does that not sound like a great function and feature of a company? Listen, stop wasting money on things you don't use, all right? Cancel your unwanted subscriptions.
再也不用长时间等待客服接听，也不用发那些烦人的客服邮件了。Rocket Money 会为你代劳一切。Rocket Money 甚至可以帮你协商降低账单。耶，最高可降 20% 左右。你所需要做的就是拍下你的账单照片，剩下的就交给 Rocket Money 处理。我的意思是，这难道没有意义吗？这听起来难道不是一家公司很棒的功能和特色吗？听着，别再把钱浪费在你不用的东西上了，好吗？取消你不需要的订阅。
Manage your money the easy way. Go to rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless. Rocketmoney.com slash Smartless. That's rocketMoney.com slash Smartless. RocketMoney.com slash Smartless, I said. Smartless is supported by Airbnb. Smartless listener, have you ever stayed in an Airbnb and thought to yourself, hey, you know what this actually seems pretty doable?
用简单的方式管理你的资金。访问 rocketmoney.com/smartless。网址是 rocketmoney.com/smartless。rocketmoney.com/Smartless。我说了，是 rocketMoney.com/Smartless。SmartLess 得到了 Airbnb 的支持。SmartLess 的听众们，你们有没有住过 Airbnb，然后心里想：“嘿，你知道吗，这个其实看起来挺可行的？”
Maybe my place could be an Airbnb. Well, maybe it really could be. It could be as simple as starting with a spare room or your whole place when you're away. You can be sitting on an Airbnb. You don't even know it. You know, like let's say you got a vacation plan for the summer. And while you're away, there's some big sports event that's coming into your city, use your house, you know, just like put it up,
也许我的房子也可以变成一个 Airbnb。嗯，也许它真的可以。其实很简单，可以从一间空房开始，或者在你不在家时出租整套房子。你可能正坐在一个潜在的 Airbnb 上，而你甚至还不知道。你知道的，比如假设你夏天有度假计划。当你不在家的时候，你所在的城市会举办什么大型体育赛事，把你的房子挂上去，你知道的，
see what you get. If you don't get a price that you like, you take it off. I mean, I don't know, this seems to make sense to me, but you know best. You do what's right for you, unrenting my house. Whether you could use a little extra money to cover some bills or for something, or a little more fun, your home or spare room
看看能租多少钱。如果你觉得价格不合适，你可以把它撤下来。我的意思是，我不知道，这对我来说挺合理的，但你最清楚。做对你最合适的事，取消出租我的房子。无论你是想用一点额外的钱来支付一些账单，还是为了做点别的，或者多一点乐趣，你的家或空房间
might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at Airbnb.com slash host. Our deep, deep sincere and heartfelt thanks to Zippercrooter for their support gang. Let me tell you a little bit about Zippercrooter, okay? If you're hiring, you know that it's incredibly hard to attract top talent, and with the current labor market conditions, well, it's even harder than ever. That's why you want a partner who gets it. Zippercrooter.
可能比你想象的更值钱。访问 Airbnb.com/host 了解具体价值。我们对 ZipRecruiter 的支持表示最深、最真诚、发自内心的感谢，各位。让我向大家介绍一下 ZipRecruiter，好吗？如果你正在招聘，你就会知道吸引顶级人才有多么困难，而鉴于目前的劳动力市场状况，嗯，这比以往任何时候都更难。这就是为什么你需要一个真正懂行的合作伙伴。ZipRecruiter。
Zippercrooter knows how tough it is right now, but they've figured out solutions for the problems that you're facing. See for yourself. Right now, you can try them for free at zippercruder.com slash smartless. Zippercruder is ready to tackle your recruiting challenges. To teach more of the right people, Zippercruder, post your job to 100 plus job sites. Need to hire ASAP? Zippercruder smart technology finds great matches for your job sooner. Want first dibs on talent? Zippercrooter lets you invite the most qualified people to apply to your job. Plus Zippercrooter's pricing is straightforward. No surprise costs.
ZipRecruiter 深知眼下的招聘有多艰难，但他们已经为你面临的问题找到了解决方案。亲自体验一下吧。现在，你可以免费试用他们的服务，网址是 zippercruder.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter 已准备好应对你的招聘挑战。为了触达更多合适的人选，ZipRecruiter 会将你的职位发布到 100 多个求职网站上。需要尽快招人？ZipRecruiter 的智能技术能更快地为你的职位找到绝佳匹配。想优先挑选人才？ZipRecruiter 允许你邀请最合格的人选来申请你的职位。此外，ZipRecruiter 的定价非常透明。没有隐藏成本。
Team up with a hiring partner who understands what you need. Zippercrooter, four out of five employers who post on Zippercrooter, get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to this exclusive web address to try Zippercrooter for free. Zippercrooter.com slash smartless. Again, that's zippercrooter.com slash smartlews. Zippercrooter, the smartest way to hire. the smartest way to hire. And now, back to the show. Now, what's to stop? What's to stop anybody watching the show when you guys don't take something
与真正理解你需求的招聘合作伙伴并肩作战。ZipRecruiter，在 ZipRecruiter 上发布招聘信息的雇主中，五分之四的人在第一天内就能获得优质候选人。只需访问这个专属网址即可免费试用 ZipRecruiter。zippercruder.com/smartless。再次强调，网址是 zippercruder.com/smartlews。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。最聪明的招聘方式。现在，让我们回到节目中。那么，当你们在节目中没有看中某个创意时，有什么能阻止其他人去偷 Sean 和 Scott 的时间呢？
for somebody to steal Sean and Scott out of the time? Yeah, it really happens all the time. Like if we don't make a deal, and sometimes even when we do, there'll be somebody and investor out there watching the show and do a quicker. And we'll just get a hold of them and say, I'll offer you more money.
对，这真的时常发生。比如如果我们没有达成交易，有时甚至在我们达成交易的时候，也会有其他的观众和投资者在看节目，然后下手更快。他们会直接联系他们，说：“我给你更多的钱。”
Oh really? And when I'm fine with that, right? It helps the entrepreneurs and it's great for them. But you're saying does anybody see the idea on TV and then steal it? And steal it, yeah. Oh no, and then do the same thing themselves. Correct.
哦，真的吗？而且我也觉得没问题，对吧？这能帮助创业者，对他们来说是件好事。但你的意思是，有没有人会在电视上看到这个创意然后把它偷走？然后偷走它，对。哦不，然后自己做一样的东西。没错。
Oh yeah, typically not because it's hard to do, right? Look, or is there enough of a delay on airing the show that you guys typically have your business done before? And we can, yeah, we can, but it's hard to see. I mean, look, everybody's got good ideas, right? You get that feeling in your stomach, and then you go to your friends, is this a good idea? Right, right.
哦，是的，通常不会，因为这很难做到，对吧？你看，或者说节目的播出有一定的延迟，通常在播出前你们的业务就已经谈妥了？我们可以，是的，我们可以，但很难说。我的意思是，你看，每个人都有好创意，对吧？你心里会有那种感觉，然后你去找你的朋友问：“这是个好创意吗？”对吧，对吧？
And then you look on Google, I'll know what he's done. If nobody tells you that it's not there for a reason. Right. But, you know, but then the hard part is actually doing it, right? Most people just don't have, you know, The gumption to go out there and actually try it and do it. I had what's been the most successful product to come out of Shark Tank So there was the thing called the comfy that Barbara Corklin did the comfy the comfy, right? That like that blanket that you wear? Oh yeah, people bought that.
然后你在谷歌上搜一下，我就知道他做了什么。如果没有人告诉你，那它不在那里是有原因的。对吧。但是，你知道，困难的部分其实是付诸行动，对吧？大多数人只是没有……你知道的，那种出去真正尝试并付诸行动的勇气。我拥有过《创智赢家》历史上最成功的的产品吗？当时有一样东西叫“The Comfy”，是芭芭拉·柯克兰（Barbara Corklin）做的，The Comfy，The Comfy，对吧？就是那种可以穿在身上的毯子？哦对，人们都买那个。
It was a knock off another product just that was a snuggy. The snuggy was like a better snuggy, right? Wow. Is it better than the snuggy? I don't know. It was just more comfy. More comfy, okay.
那是对另一个产品的山寨，那个产品是 Snuggy。Snuggy 就像是一个改良版的 Snuggy，对吧？哇。它比 Snuggy 更好吗？我不知道。它只是更舒服。更舒服，好吧。
And so the guy comes in and it's kind of like fallen apart a little bit, but they're comfortable in everything. And Barbara offers them like $50,000 for 25% of the company. And no lie, she has made just herself $37 million in Canada. Oh my God. They have sold like $400 million worth of companies.
然后那家伙走进来，当时公司有点要散伙的意思，但他们做得很舒服，一切都挺好。然后芭芭拉出资 5 万美元换取他们公司 25% 的股份。说实话，她单凭这个在加拿大就赚了 3700 万美元。哦，天哪。他们的公司已经卖了大约 4 亿美元。
Wow. And I say the same thing to Barbara every time I see her. Fuck you, what did I do that deal? Right, yeah. I mean, what- Barber's the best. Like, like, like, how many- how many companies do you own or have- Have- our invested in it, and even time?
哇。我每次见到芭芭拉都会对她说同样的话：“他妈的，我怎么没做那笔交易？”对吧，耶。我的意思是，什么——芭芭拉是最棒的。比如，比如，比如，你有多少——你有多少家公司是自己拥有或者投资过的？
Like, you know, 200 to 250. How do you keep track of them? I don't. I don't. You've got these little just- If you want to know my companies, another piece, MarkCuban.com, and you can see all of them and that literally really That's how I remember my companies I go to the website. Do you? Do you want to buy a podcast for a billion dollars?
比如，你知道的，200 到 250 家。你是怎么追踪它们的？我没有。我没有。你只要把这些小东西——如果你想了解我的公司，还有另一个地方，MarkCuban.com，你可以在那儿看到所有公司，真的就是这样。这就是我记住自己公司的方式，我直接上网站。是吗？你想花十亿美元买一个播客吗？
So will I'm gonna tell you this think about it Sean wanted cash $2 million per 2% right? So that's $100 million valuation. Yes. So when we get his $100 million valuation and sell that for a billion, we'll use it to buy the podcast. There you go. Mark, when you open the paper in the morning, do you check the sports page first or the business
所以，Will，我要告诉你这个，你想想看：Sean 想要现金，200 万美元占 2% 的股份，对吧？所以估值是 1 亿美元。没错。所以当我们拿到他这 1 亿美元的估值，然后以 10 亿美元把它卖掉时，我们就用这笔钱来买这个播客。给你。马克，你早晨翻看报纸时，是先看体育版还是商业版
for it to see the stocks? Like what's the paper? Don't watch Shark Tank, but you open a paper. I know. business to see the stocks. Like what's the pay for? Don't watch Shark Tank, but you open a paper. I know. Anyway, you're getting a real good idea of what he's all about. Granddad, here spends a lot of time in slippers. No, but what's your favorite sports page?
来看股票？报纸是什么样的？不看《创智赢家》，但你翻看报纸。我知道。看商业版来了解股票。报纸是什么样的？不看《创智赢家》，但你翻看报纸。我知道。不管怎样，你对他是怎样的人有了很好的了解。这里的爷爷花了很多时间穿拖鞋。不，不过你最喜欢哪个体育版？
Because sometimes people follow stocks like they fall a team. No, I do the both. So I check all the sports on Bleach and Report. And then I check, there's this Mimeo random thing that I check, just general news news and then tech meme so there's I have my websites that I go through every morning but sports first typically Yeah, because it takes two seconds just to check the score. Yeah. Yeah. Well, do you like you enjoy any other sports other than basketball? Yeah, I love I mean, I like all sports. I played rugby in college
因为有时人们关注股票就像关注一支球队一样。不，我两个都看。所以我会在 Bleacher Report 上查看所有的体育新闻。然后我会看，有一个类似 Mimio 的随机东西我会看，就是一般的综合新闻，还有 TechMeme，所以我有自己每天必看的网站，不过通常先看体育。耶，因为花两秒钟查一下比分就可以了。耶。耶。好吧，除了篮球，你还喜欢其他运动吗？耶，我喜欢，我的意思是，我喜欢所有运动。我上大学时打过橄榄球。
So that literally is my my second sport, but I'm a fan of football and baseball and all that stuff. Would you ever wanna buy a team in another sport? I looked at buying the cubs, I looked at buying the pirate. Wow. They wouldn't let me buy the cubs. Why? They wouldn't let me. Major League Baseball didn't want me in. Why?
所以那真的是我的第二运动，不过我是橄榄球、棒球以及所有这些东西的球迷。你有没有想过在其他运动中买下一支球队？我考虑过买小熊队，我考虑过买海盗队。哇。他们不让我买小熊队。为什么？他们不让我买。美国职业棒球大联盟（Major League Baseball）不让我加入。为什么？
Yeah, they were afraid. Well, but what makes you an unattractive owner to Major League Baseball? All that stuff about the referees we talked about? Yeah, they don't like that. Too opinionated is too much of an old boys club. Yeah, very much so. Yeah, they literally told me no chance.
耶，他们害怕。好吧，但是是什么让你成为美国职业棒球大联盟一个不受欢迎的老板？我们刚才聊过的关于裁判的那些事？耶，他们不喜欢那样。意见太多，老派作风太严重了。耶，确实如此。耶，他们直接对我说没门。
I played almost. So talk shit about him if there's no chance. Let's air it. I mean. I mean, they have their own baseballs got their own problems. I don't even need to talk shit about it Yeah, yeah, some things are so fucked up. Yeah, it speaks for itself. What about soccer? Do you see? Soccer is a is an incredible what what I call football
我差点就买成了。所以如果没有机会的话，就狠狠吐槽他们吧。把它播出去。我是说。我是说，棒球有它自己的问题。我甚至不需要去吐槽它。耶，耶，有些事情太操蛋了。耶，不言自明。那足球呢？你觉得呢？足球是一项令人难以置信的，我称之为足球的运动。
I'm a big premier league football. Yeah, love it love it love it. I don't yeah, right? Which team liverpool is my team. We got him. Yeah. And all right, cool it. And I love watching it. And it's growing. And it's getting even more popular in this country. And the US looks like it's going to qualify probably for the World Cup, which is great.
我是英超联赛的超级球迷。耶，太喜欢了，太喜欢了。我不——耶，对吧？哪支球队？利物浦是我的球队。我们拥有他们。耶。好吧，冷静点。我喜欢看比赛。而且它在不断发展。在这个国家它正变得越来越受欢迎。而且美国看起来很有可能会获得世界杯的参赛资格，这太棒了。
Just below Canada. And I don't make the scores up. And is that something that you could see that's gonna grow in this country? Yeah, soccer's growing. The biggest challenge is it's not a great TV sport. That's what I'm saying. That's what I'm saying.
就在加拿大后面。我不编造比分。你觉得这是一项在这个国家会不断发展的运动吗？耶，足球正在发展。最大的挑战是它不是一项很好的电视体育转播。这就是我想说的。这就是我想说的。
Right? Yeah, see? That's what I'm saying. It's like, it's like. But I bet you could come up with a different way to shoot that sport or come up with some sort of technology to make it more interesting. No. The good thing about soccer is when you go to a game it's amazing.
对吧？耶，你看？这就是我想说的。这就像是，这就像是。但我打赌你可以想出一种不同的方式来拍摄这项运动，或者想出某种技术让它变得更有趣。不。足球的好处在于，当你去现场看比赛时，它棒极了。
Yeah. Right. It's very much experiential, kind of like hockey, right? Go into a hockey game. Yeah, but it's like they score a goal. You could run to the store and come back and it's like, oh, yeah. But there's more to it. It's a beautiful, faster than baseball.
耶。对吧。它非常有体验感，有点像曲棍球，对吧？去看一场曲棍球比赛。耶，但这就好像他们进了一个球。你可以跑到商店买东西然后回来，然后就会觉得：“哦，耶。”但其中还有更多门道。它很美，比棒球节奏快。
Yeah, that's why baseball's got to it. It's the beautiful, faster than baseball. Yeah, that's why baseball's got it. I heard one time that they looked at all the major sports and they decided which ones were the best for watching on television and they're on a scale. Football was the best for the amount of plays and then breaks. Because there's only 15 minutes of football in a game. Right. You can go take a B-shit, you can get something to eat and then you can go back in the next day.
耶，这就是为什么棒球……它是如此美妙，比棒球节奏快。耶，这就是为什么棒球有……我曾经听说他们研究了所有主流体育项目，并评判了哪些最适合在电视上观看，他们有一个评分标准。美式足球是最适合的，因为它的进攻配合和中场休息比例很合适。因为一场橄榄球比赛里只有 15 分钟的净比赛时间。对吧。你可以去拉个屎，你可以去吃点东西，然后你可以接着看下一场。
You can go back and they've done 50 replays, and they've done whatever, and it goes all the way down. And the far end is hockey, my other passion. And yeah, and I know there's a big hockey town, and I'm a big trotter, may please, Finn. Is that been working out? Actually, well, you know. Let's not get real, Mark.
你可以回去，而他们已经放了 50 遍回放，做完了所有事情，然后一直排下去。排在最末端的是曲棍球，我的另一个挚爱。耶，我知道这是个曲棍球大镇，我是个狂热的……枫叶队球迷，芬。那行得通吗？其实吧，你知道的。我们别太较真了，马克。
And so hockey's down there, and then soccer's down there as well. So it's, it's problem is, you know, basketball, you can, basketball's problem on TV is it's 48 minutes of basketball, right? But it's great for social media because there's so many highlights and so on TikTok, on Twitter and whatever, basketball is number one. Right, and so now what's gonna happen?
所以曲棍球排在后面，足球也在后面。所以它的问题在于，你知道的，篮球，篮球在电视上的问题是它有 48 分钟的篮球比赛，对吧？但它非常适合社交媒体，因为有太多的精彩集锦，所以在 TikTok、Twitter 以及各种平台上，篮球排名第一。对吧，那么现在会发生什么呢？
Everybody, we all watch a lot of our content streaming, right? And more of a, and how did that start? Now that you know? From you. What? Yeah. So my question to you is this, now as more and more people
大家，我们都在流媒体上观看大量的内容，对吧？而且越来越多地，它是如何开始的？既然你知道了？从你开始。什么？耶。所以我对你的问题是这样的，现在越来越多的人
are shedding their cable or shedding their satellite or whatever, how is that going to? What's going to happen to live sports, do you think? What's going to change a lot? It's going to change a lot. Jason, have you ever been on TikTok? No. You don't know how to do renegade renegade Sean Sean does enough tiktok for the whole house yeah I don't really but
正在抛弃他们的有线电视或卫星电视之类的东西，这将会怎么样？你认为对现场体育赛事会发生什么？会有很大改变吗？会有很大改变。杰森，你玩过 TikTok 吗？没有。你不会跳叛逆者舞吗？Sean，Sean 在 TikTok 上花的时间够全家用的了。耶，我其实不——
but you're very popular on tiktok with your kids too right you can't see I love doing this I love that I love that's much wait go back to what were you just talking about so we're talking about watching TV in the future. Yeah, it's gonna be a future of live sports. So for us, what for us? Yeah. It's gonna be more like, I love watching football. Just billionaires. Right.
但你在 TikTok 上和孩子们一起也非常受欢迎，对吧？你看不到——我喜欢这样做，我喜欢那个，我喜欢——等等，回到你刚才在说什么？所以我们在谈论未来看电视。耶，这将是现场体育赛事的未来。所以对我们来说，对我们来说？耶。它会更像是，我喜欢看足球。只是亿万富翁们。对吧。
No. Wait, did we, did this deal go through? Do we just sell the podcast? Oh my God, we're stocking the Donnie, this washer company. That's so interesting. I watched football now. I'm really interested. I'm really into football.
不。等等，我们，这笔交易谈成了吗？我们刚刚把播客卖了吗？哦，天哪，我们正在囤积唐尼的洗碗机公司。太有趣了。我现在看足球了。我真的很有兴趣。我真的很迷足球。
Sometimes I'll watch baseball, but it's kind of like watching this old house. It's just like, you know, I'm at the back. I feel like I always shows up. I know. Well, the new guy, Kevin. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's great, but baseball, basketball,
有时我会看棒球，但那有点像看《老房子重建》（This Old House）。就好像，你知道的，我在后面。我觉得总是有人出现。我知道。好吧，新来的那个家伙，凯文。耶，耶，耶。他很棒，但棒球、篮球，
you know, I went to a Lakers game once, and it's actually more thrilling to watch it live, right? When you're there, it's like, I can't when it smells like high school, and it's really cool, and it's like, right, and I'm sitting there on the sidelines, and with my straight friend Steve Shenbaum, who's so funny, and he's married.
你知道的，我曾经去现场看过一场湖人队的比赛，现场观看其实更刺激，对吧？当你在现场时，那种感觉就像——我不能——当它闻起来像高中时，真的很酷，就像，对，我正坐在场边，跟我那个直男朋友史蒂夫·申鲍姆（Steve Shenbaum）在一起，他太有趣了，而且他已经结婚了。
Wait, do you say that about us, my straight friend Will and Mr. all the time? Do you really? Yeah, all the time. So then, so I'm sitting there, I'm sitting at a Lakers game. And you know when they do that, they do a lot of stadiums.
等等，你对我们说过类似的话吗，我直男朋友威尔和——先生，一直都在？真的吗？耶，一直都这样。所以当时，所以我坐在那里，我正坐在湖人队的比赛现场。你知道他们会在很多体育馆里搞的那一套吗？
But they play that, um, kiss me. And that, it's like the kiss cam. Kiss cam, yeah. And the people like Will Smith and his wife are there. And like all these, and they catch them. And they put it on me and my straight friend Steve. And I'm looking up and I'm like, oh my God, we're bigger than the whole fucking building. And their one is the Chris and everybody's laughing. And he's panicking. And I'm looking up and I'm like, oh my God, we're bigger than the whole fucking building.
但他们会放那个，嗯，亲亲我（Kiss Me）。就好像是“亲吻镜头”（Kiss Cam）。亲吻镜头，对。人们就像威尔·史密斯和他的妻子也在那儿。就像所有这些人在那儿，他们抓拍到了他们。然后他们把镜头对准了我跟我直男朋友史蒂夫。我抬头一看，心想：“哦，天哪，我们比整栋该死的建筑还要大。”然后其中一个是 Chris，每个人都在笑。他在惊慌失措。我抬头一看，心想：“哦，天哪，我们比整栋该死的建筑还要大。”
And their one is the Chris and everybody's laughing and he's panicking and I'm panicking. So I just made out with my hand. Oh boy. That's another dumb story. You were talking about your kids. Tell us, what's family life like? Is it normal?
然后其中一个是 Chris，每个人都在笑，他在惊慌失措，我也在惊慌失措。所以我索性跟我的手亲热起来。哦，天哪。这又是另一个蠢故事。你刚才谈到了你的孩子们。给我们讲讲，家庭生活是什么样的？很正常吗？
Is it crazy? Is it, do they want to do what you do? Yeah, and do you teach them about money? And did somebody teach you about money when you were a kid? No one taught me about money. I mean, because it didn't have much, right? You just, you had to work and just do your thing. But like with my kids, obviously, my kids are 12, Jake,
很疯狂吗？是这样吗，他们想做和你一样的事吗？耶，你教他们理财吗？你小时候有人教你理财吗？没有人教我理财。我的意思是，因为当时没有太多钱，对吧？你只能，你必须工作，做好你分内的事。但对于我的孩子们，显然，我的孩子们是 12 岁的杰克，
15, Alyssa, and 18, Alexis. And literally Alyssa, my 15-year-old, and I watch Will and Grace, like all the time, right? That's right there. Yeah, and Ozark with Alexis. Jake, not so much. I'm sorry, but that's okay. Like I'm asking.
15 岁的艾莉莎（Alyssa），还有 18 岁的亚历克西斯（Alexis）。老实说，艾莉莎，我 15 岁的女儿，和我经常一起看《威尔与格蕾丝》（Will and Grace），对吧？就在那里。耶，还有和亚历克西斯一起看《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）。杰克就看得少一些。很抱歉，不过没关系。我只是随口问问。
I'm cool. But it's scary. Check out Murderville. You got to check out Murderville. Murderville, I never really- I just downloaded it. I just downloaded it. It's fun. I'll go sit in the audience.
我很酷。但这挺吓人的。去看看《怪探》（Murderville）吧。你一定要去看看《怪探》。《怪探》，我其实没——我刚刚下载了。我刚才下载了。挺有意思的。我去观众席坐着。
But now... So, they're not like young entrepreneurs already? Oh, my son Jake. Yeah. Definitely an entrepreneur. Really? Oh my God. I'm like Jake.
但现在……所以，他们还不是那种少年创业者？哦，我儿子杰克。耶。绝对是个创业者。真的吗？哦，天哪。我真像杰克。
I was in his room two days ago. Jake, what's that candy on his little baby refrigerator there? And what do you have that candy there? He goes, oh, I sold it to my friend at school and I'm gonna make about $15. Wow. And I'm like, yeah, that's my guy. Yeah, my guy.
两天前我在他房间里。杰克，他那个小迷你冰箱上的糖果是什么？你为什么把糖果放在那儿？他说，哦，我把它卖给我学校的朋友了，我要赚大约 15 美元。哇。我就想，耶，这才是我的好样。耶，我的好样。
Did you see any crochet dinosaurs in there? Yeah, my guy. No, but no. No. Okay, so he has to work. That's the age, you know. What would you tell somebody who's starting out? I'm sorry?
你在里面看到什么钩针织的恐龙了吗？耶，我的好样。不，不过没有。没有。好吧，所以他必须工作。这就是那个年纪，你知道的。你会对刚起步的人说些什么？抱歉？
Nothing. I think I know that story. I just learned about the whole sock about a year ago. I don't know what that is. You know what I'm going to go. It doesn't matter. So what would you tell? So somebody, like one of these young people
没什么。我想我知道那个故事。我大约在一年前才刚知道那个整袜子的事。我不知道那是什么。你知道的，我要走了。没关系。那你打算告诉谁？所以某个人，比如这里的这些年轻人，
in the audience here, they're young, they've gotten out of college, they've got the first job, they've got, you know. Has nobody here? Yeah, and. And. Not true. Not true, there's that guy right there.
现场的这些年轻人，他们还年轻，刚大学毕业，找到了第一份工作，他们有……这里没有人吗？耶，还有。还有。不对。不对，那边就有一个家伙。
Number one, he said. Number one. And he's got, he's got a paycheck, he did a thing, he's got $1,000. What does he put his money into? What does he do? All right, first, you want to learn a little bit about crypto if you have a thousand dollars.
第一名，他说。第一名。他有薪水，他做成了一件事，他有 1,000 美元。他把钱投到哪里？他该做什么？好吧，首先，如果你有一千美元的话，你想对加密货币略知一二。
Okay. Yeah, well that's just for real. But, but, you don't want to speculate, right? So I had this conversation last night with two of my Indiana friends, right? And I don't understand using money to buy money. I don't. Yeah, do you have the real low-brown,
好吧。耶，好吧，那只是为了现实点。但是，但是，你不想去投机，对吧？所以我昨晚和我两个印第安纳的朋友讨论过这件事，对吧？我不理解用钱去买钱。我不理解。耶，你能用那种非常粗浅、笨拙的解释来解释一下加密货币吗？
knuckle-dragging explanation for crypto? Yeah, right. Because I don't get it, and I'm not smart. So put aside the coin part of it, right? There's just a different way to create applications. Just like the early days of the internet, it didn't seem to make sense, right? When Amazon first came out, everybody would say, well, don't give them your credit card.
耶，对吧？因为我搞不懂，而且我不聪明。所以撇开它的代币部分不谈，对吧？这只是一种创建应用程序的不同方式。就像互联网的早期一样，它当时看起来似乎也没什么意义，对吧？当亚马逊刚问世时，每个人都说，好吧，别把你的信用卡给他们。
You don't know what Amazon is going to do with your credit card. You can't trust that. It was hard, and people didn't understand it. Now with crypto, there's a lot of noise, but there's different applications that you can download and buy these things called stablecoins. There's one in particular that I buy called USDC and the thing about it is you can earn more interest on that USDC stablecoin, 4% 5% depending on where you're at a little bit more and it's relatively safe, right?
你不知道亚马逊会用你的信用卡做什么。你不能信任那个。这很难，人们当时并不理解。现在对于加密货币，有很多噪音，但有不同的应用程序，你可以下载并购买这些名为稳定币的东西。其中有一种我特别买的叫 USDC，关于它的事情是，你可以在那个 USDC 稳定币上赚取更多利息，4%、5%，取决于你所处的位置可能会多一点，而且它相对安全，对吧？
It's not as safe as being in the bank because there's no FDIC insurance, but I put money there and I recommended to my friend, two of my friends here, that just made a little bit of money, you had a couple thousand dollars, that to take part of it and go to an app, voyeurgercrypto.com, whatever it may be, and put it in there and earn your 4%. But this is what I'm saying. Why are you putting, I don't understand,
它没有存在银行里那么安全，因为没有联邦存款保险公司（FDIC）的保险，但我把钱放在那里，我向我的朋友，我这里的两个朋友推荐了它，他们刚刚赚了一点钱，你手里有几千美元，把一部分拿出来，去一个应用，voyeurgercrypto.com，无论它叫什么，然后把钱放进去，赚取你的 4% 的利息。但这正是我要说的。为什么你要把，我不理解，
you're putting your own money to buy money. It's my thing a minute. It's my thing a minute. So is it like investing in a stock market. Is that what it is? It's not really, it's more like if you were going to do currency exchanges, right? Because it's different types of currency. But because they use them to trade, they pay higher interest rates than they do in a bank.
你是在用自己的钱去买钱。这是我的观点。这是我的观点。所以这就像投资股市吗？是这样吗？其实不然，这更像是你要去做货币兑换，对吧？因为它是不同类型的货币。但因为他们用它们来交易，所以它们支付的利率比银行要高。
Because you're not going to earn anything from your savings account, your checking account or whatever, right? And you might think of this as life. You think that there's one day, one day we're not going to use, because it's a lot of junk out there, right? Just like in the early days of the internet, right? There might have been 100 to one shitty companies to good companies.
因为你在储蓄账户、支票账户或者其他什么账户里根本赚不到任何利息，对吧？你可能会把这视为生活。你认为总有一天，总有一天我们不会再使用它了，因为外面有很多垃圾，对吧？就像互联网的早期一样，对吧？垃圾公司与好公司的比例可能会达到 100 比 1。
Yeah, right. And because it's the early day still of crypto, it's going to take time for the nonsense, the noise and the dirt to find its way. So you would recommend, what is it? USDC. USDC over Bitcoin or something like that. Yeah, Bitcoin, like I'm glad, I'm glad you repeated that.
耶，对吧。而且因为现在仍然是加密货币的早期，需要时间来让那些无意义的东西、噪音和泥沙沉淀下去。所以你会推荐，叫什么来着？USDC。比起比特币或其他之类的，推荐 USDC。耶，比特币，就像我很高兴，我很高兴你重复了那句话。
I almost bought a bunch of USDA steaks. Yeah, right? Yeah. Um. Mark, you've been told me to buy the steak, haven't you? I'm not earning shit. Bitcoin's kind of like, Bitcoin's kind of like digital gold, right? Yeah.
我差一点就买了一堆 USDA（美国农业部）牛排。耶，对吧？嗯。马克，你一直在叫我买牛排，对吧？我一点利息都没赚到。比特币有点像，比特币有点像数字黄金，对吧？耶。
So old people buy gold and younger people are going to buy Bitcoin just because it makes more sense. You can't see it or touch or anything, but it would. So when it was the last time someone bought gold and they could touch it, right? Exactly. Because everything is so tight anyway. Yeah, yeah. And so Bitcoin is a store value and it's going to go up and down
所以老年人买黄金，年轻人会买比特币，只是因为它更有意义。你看不到也摸不到它任何东西，但它确实是。所以上一次有人买黄金并且能摸到它是什么时候，对吧？完全正确。因为反正所有东西都这么紧缩。耶，耶。所以比特币是一种价值储藏手段，它会上涨和下跌，
like you see it go up and down. I like Ethereum a little bit more because it has more applications, utility. It's going to go up and down. But it's not something that I'm telling people, look, just go all in. It's like the stock market, right? Just take ten bucks. Just take ten bucks or a hundred bucks or so.
就像你看到它上下波动一样。我更喜欢以太坊一点，因为它有更多的应用场景和实用性。它也会上下波动。但这并不是那种我告诉人们“看吧，直接全仓压上”的东西。这就像股市一样，对吧？只拿十块钱。只拿十块钱或一百块钱左右。
Try it, right? That's why I like Dogecoin, right? Dogecoin is silly as hell, but this is how I introduced my son to crypto, right? This is back, we opened up a Robinhood account, and I showed him he could buy Dogecoin back when it was like a penny, right? And so we spent $7 and now it's $0.15 and so you can you can buy some just to see what it's about That's interesting. And spend five bucks. Yeah, yeah, and so and then get to learn it. All right, so listen you Before I let you go because I know you got to go
去试试，对吧？这就是为什么我喜欢狗狗币（Dogecoin），对吧？狗狗币傻透了，但这就是我向我儿子介绍加密货币的方式，对吧？这是以前的事了，我们开了一个 Robinhood 账户，我向他展示了他在狗狗币只有一分钱左右的时候就可以买它，对吧？所以我们花了 7 美元，现在它价值 0.15 美元，所以你可以买一些来了解它到底是是怎么回事。这挺有意思的。花五块钱。耶，耶，所以然后去了解它。好吧，听着，
You have you have a personality this huge personality which is so intoxicating and it's, you seem like such a good guy. He is, well, he's so glad to meet you. Yeah, I love it. Thank you. He seems so incredible. Fascinating. Thanks for having me on, guys.
在我让你离开之前，因为我知道你得走了，你有着这样一种人格，这种巨大的个人魅力，实在是太迷人了，而且你看上去是个这么好的人。他是，哦，很高兴认识你。耶，我喜欢。谢谢。他看起来太不可思议了。太迷人了。谢谢邀请我上节目，伙计们。
You've been a blast. Yeah, thank you. Before you go, I want to ask you, you always seem to be, by the way, back to Shark Tank for just two seconds. You know what I love when you do? You always let people down, I love it. When people are like going on and you just raise your? You always let people down. I love it.
你们太棒了。耶，谢谢。在你走之前，我想问你，你总是显得——顺便说一句，回到《创智赢家》两秒钟。你知道我最喜欢你什么时候吗？你总是让人们失望，我太喜欢了。当人们还在滔滔不绝时，你只是举起你的？你总是让人们失望。我太喜欢了。
When people are like going on and you just raise your head, just let you go. Thank you for coming. Thank you. Thank you. That's all. Thank you. I love that.
当人们还在滔滔不绝时，你只是举起你的头，就让他们走。谢谢你们来。谢谢。谢谢。就这样。谢谢。我太喜欢了。
I try to be nice, give us some advice, right? Good luck. That's what you say. Good luck, which is so like get out. So, yeah, it's just another way of saying fuck you. Yeah, I love it. I didn't say that we're all dead. I know, I know.
我尽量表现得友善，给我们一些建议，对吧？祝你好运。这就是你说的。祝你好运，这太像“滚蛋”了。所以，耶，这只是说“去你妈的”的另一种说法。耶，我喜欢。我可没说我们全都死透了。我知道，我知道。
But I love it. So as someone who's in charge of a lot of things and a lot of business, you just seem to always be in control. Who's the one that controls you and brings you down to Earth? And is there somebody that can tell you, you don't mark shut the fuck up, you need to get real. Oh yeah, well, I wasn't kids. Yeah.
但我太喜欢了。所以作为一个掌控着很多事情和许多生意的人，你似乎总是能掌控全局。谁是那个能够控制你并把你拉回现实的人？有没有人能对你说：“马克，闭上你他妈的嘴，你得现实一点”？哦，耶，好吧，还有孩子们。耶。
But anybody beyond your family? I'll be on my family. The raft. The rafts. Like you said. The rafts, yeah. I try to listen to every, look, look, I try to learn from everybody, you know?
不过除了你的家人之外呢？超越我的家人。木筏。木筏。就像你说的。木筏，耶。我试着听取每一个人的意见，看吧，看吧，我试着向所有人学习，你知道吗？
So if someone's got to tell me to, like, you know, in all my businesses, there's somebody that will tell me to shut the fuck up, right? I don't mind it at all. So if I fuck up, tell me I fucked up. I don't care, right? Because. And you wanna know.
所以如果有人要对我说，比如说，你知道的，在我所有的生意里，都会有人叫我闭上他妈的嘴，对吧？我一点也不介意。所以如果我搞砸了，就告诉我我搞砸了。我不在乎，对吧？因为。而且你想知道。
Yeah, I wanna know when I fuck up all the time. We talked about that the other day. We were talking about this idea. It's like when you're doing that, especially amongst friends, you have to have that ability to go, please let me know, because it's going to help me. And my friends are like my high school friends. I've been friends with since, you know, I've six years old.
耶，我随时都想知道自己什么时候搞砸了。我们前几天还聊过这个。我们在讨论这个想法。就像当你这样做的时候，尤其是在朋友之间，你必须具备那种能力去说：“请告诉我，因为这会对我有所帮助。”而我的朋友们就像是我的高中朋友。我从——你知道的，我六岁起就和他们是朋友了。
Yeah, you've got to come up with old buddies here. Yeah, well, yeah. And so my college friends, they'll all tell me to shut the fuck up, right? And you know, they don't give up. Are they blown away? The guys that you grew up with in high school and college, or they're used to it by now, because it's been a minute that you've been really successful.
耶，你得带上这里的老死党。耶，好吧，耶。所以我的大学朋友们，他们都会叫我闭上他妈的嘴，对吧？而且你知道的，他们从不放弃。他们被惊艳到了吗？那些跟你一起在高中和大学长大的家伙们，还是他们现在已经习以为常了，因为你获得巨大成功已经有一会儿了？
But do you guys, do you have those moments with each other where you go? Can you believe this shit all the time? Good, yeah, all the time. And look, I mean, there's not a day. Do you have the best of their money for them? No, okay. No, that's too much stress. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
但是你们，你们之间会有那种时刻吗，就是你们会说：“你敢相信这所有的破事吗？”很好，耶，一直都有。而且你看，我的意思是，没有一天——你帮他们理财吗？不，好吧。不，那压力太大了。耶，耶，耶。
But there's not a day that doesn't go by where I'm just like, how the fuck this happened to me? Because seriously, yeah. We feel the same way. Yeah, right. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, we're really good. We're really good.
但没有一天过去我是不这样想的：“这他妈的怎么发生在我身上的？”因为说真的，耶。我们有同感。耶，对吧。耶，耶，耶。不，我们真的很好。我们真的很好。
Yeah, you got to. We really, we really do. We tell her all the time, we did a show the other night. We had our buddy Bradley Cooper was on our show in Brooklyn. And we were saying, we knew each other way back in the day. And he was like, this is so crazy that we get to do what we're doing in this way. It's fucking bizarre. It's insane. Yeah, we're so appreciative.
耶，你必须这样。我们真的，我们真的这么做了。我们总是对别人说，我们前几天做了一个节目。我们的好友布莱德利·库珀（Bradley Cooper）在我们在布鲁克林的节目上。我们在说，我们很早就认识彼此了。他说：“我们能以这种方式做我们正在做的事，这太疯狂了。这他妈的太诡异了。这太疯狂了。耶，我们非常感激。”
And we're not for you guys. We would not be able to say that. Yeah, I mean, some believe it will. Thank you. Mark, thank you for coming. I love you. Thank you for making it smarter. I learned stuff. I can't wait to watch more of Shark it will. Thank you. Mark, thank you for coming. I love you. Thank you for making it smarter. I learned stuff.
如果没有你们，我们就无法说出这句话。耶，我的意思是，有些人会相信的。谢谢。马克，谢谢你来。我爱你。谢谢你让节目变得更有智慧。我学到了东西。我迫不及待想看更多《创智赢家》了。马克，谢谢你来。我爱你。谢谢你让节目变得更有智慧。我学到了东西。
I can't wait to watch more of Shark Tank. I love you. Thank you for being here. Mark, we're going to be great, Mark. Thank you, everybody. Thanks, everybody. Thank you so much for having me, man. Thank you, pal.
我迫不及待想看更多《创智赢家》了。我爱你。谢谢你能来。马克，我们会很棒的，马克。谢谢大家。谢谢大家。非常感谢邀请我来，伙计。谢谢你，老兄。
Thank you so much for doing this. Thank you, pal. Jason, thank you so much, everybody. You have to be here. Thank you. Thank you for doing this. Thank you, everybody. Thank you so much, bud. Thank you for doing this. Thank you, thank you for doing this. Thank you, everybody. Thank you, man.
非常感谢你做这一切。谢谢你，老兄。杰森，非常感谢大家。你必须来这里。谢谢。谢谢你做这一切。谢谢大家。非常感谢，兄弟。谢谢你做这一切。谢谢，谢谢你做这一切。谢谢大家。谢谢，伙计。
Thank you. What is Scotty? What is Scotty most commonly tell you to stop doing? What we have a wonderful, it's all dark humor. I grew up with dark, dark humor, and that's what we do. No, but what is the thing that you generally... Oh, just generally. You need to fix most.
谢谢。斯科蒂是什么？斯科蒂最常告诉你不要做什么？我们有一个美妙的，这全是黑色幽默。我是在黑色、黑色幽默中长大的，这就是我们的相处方式。不，但是你通常做的那件事是……哦，只是通常。你需要修复得最多的。
Worrying. Worry, stop worrying. Yes. So, while also controlling, so Sean has been doing this thing the last week, and we notice every time we get in a car like to go to the airport or to go to the venue or whatever, we'll get in professional driver. Guy knows where he's going, And Sean's got his phone up.
担心。担忧，别再担心了。是的。所以，在控制欲强的同时，Sean 在过去的一周里一直在做一件事，我们注意到每次我们上车去机场或者去演出场地之类的时，我们都会坐上专业司机的车。那家伙知道他要去哪儿，然后 Sean 把手机举了起来。
And the guy, and he's in the back seat, and Sean goes, it's 11 minutes. And I'm like, well, there's nothing we can do about it. I know. I just like alternative routes, just in case. Anyway, so. But here's the thing. Mark Cuban is so great. I'm obsessed with Shark Tank.
那个家伙，他坐在后座上，肖恩说，要11分钟。我说，好吧，这也没办法。我知道。我只是喜欢备用路线，以防万一。总之，所以。但重点是。马克·库班太棒了。我迷上了《创智赢家》。
He was so nice to come up. Should we pool our money a little bit? Maybe like, dude. Yeah, we should, right? Yeah, why don't we all pool our money? Yeah. Should we do like a group thing? I want to...
他上来真是太好了。我们是不是该凑点钱？也许像，老兄。对，我们应该，对吧？对，我们为什么不把钱凑在一起？对。我们应该搞个团购什么的吗？我想……
Also, I like the idea of you in Scotty rehearsing your Shark Tank pitch. Yes. That's what I was doing in the other room the other night when you guys were, where are you guys going? I'm like, I'll be right back. And you guys were rehearsing there. They rehearsed a little bit.
还有，我喜欢你和斯科蒂排练《创智赢家》推销说辞的想法。是的。前几天晚上你们在的时候，我就是在另一个房间里做那个，你们去哪儿了？我说，我马上回来。然后你们在那儿排练。他们排练了一会儿。
So is that, is that how the pitches go? That's campy and they're performative, right? Yes. So, but is that a prerequisite of it? I mean, can't you just come out and say, here's my idea. No, no, because they're not actors. They're not like performers.
所以，那是，推销就是这样的吗？那种浮夸且充满表演性质的，对吧？是的。那么，这是个先决条件吗？我的意思是，难道你就不能直接走出来说，这是我的想法。不，不，因为他们不是演员。他们不是那种表演者。
But do you have to kind of, do they say, you got to put a little spice into it? Yeah, they do they go to show. Yeah, I will, but I don't know it yet. No, that's okay. I want to see where Scotty can we just get Scotty back out here? Scotty get back out here. Still alive.
但你必须，他们会说，你得加点料进去吗？对，他们会说，要带点表演。对，我会的，但我还不知道。不，没关系。我想看看斯科蒂能不能，我们能把斯科蒂叫回这儿来吗？斯科蒂，回到这儿来。还活着。
Yeah, still alive. So wait, so again, I just want to get back to, sorry, not to get tune in the nuts and bolts of it, but so when you guys are rehearsing your bit, was Sean, was Sean Superbossy? Yeah, yeah, a little bit. He was. Yeah, a little bit.
对，还活着。等等，所以再次，我只是想回到，抱歉，不是要钻牛角尖，但是当你们在排练那段词时，肖恩，肖恩是不是超级专断？对，对，有点。他是。对，有点。
Not gonna lie. Yeah, a little bit. I'd be like, he's got his diabetes pod. You got to get my MRI right there. Well, good bye. Yeah. What? Dad yet.
说实话。对，有点。我会觉得，他带着糖尿病胰岛素泵。你得把我的MRI放在那儿。好吧，再见。什么？还不是爸爸。
Not dad yet. And how many times did he make you rehearse it? Five or six, yeah. He's still in guess. And you guys, so you guys have been married a number of years now. Fifteen years, yeah. Did. Oh yeah.
还不是爸爸。他让你排练了多少次？五六次吧。他还在猜。然后你们，所以你们已经结婚好多年了。十五年了，对。有没有。哦，对。
Fifteen years. Oh, sorry, I didn't know you had in mind. No. But, did Scotty before you guys were married, did you know about the dinosaur story? Because I'm... No. No. No, but I've heard about it since. Because I'm... No. No.
十五年。哦，抱歉，我不知道你在想什么。没有。但是，斯科蒂在你们结婚之前，你知道恐龙的故事吗？因为我……没有。没有。不，但我后来听说过。因为我……没有。没有。
No, but I've heard about it since, but not before we were married. Yeah, huh. Was that affected your... Decisions. No, this is a fair question. No, no, of course. Yeah.
不，但我后来听说过，但在我们结婚之前没有。是吗，哦。这有没有影响你的……决定。不，这是一个公平的问题。不，不，当然。是的。
So, Scotty, how did you use to masturbate? Um... Right. A lot more carefully. A lot more carefully. A lot more carefully. Not with wired figures. Mr. Bate. All right. A lot more carefully. A lot more carefully. Not with wired figures. Right.
所以，斯科蒂，你以前是怎么自慰的？嗯……对。小心得多。小心得多。小心得多。不用带电线的玩偶。自慰。好的。小心得多。小心得多。不用带电线的玩偶。对。
And if somebody came in to catch you, would you say, like, don't go away? Oh, that's a bad one. Oh, my God. He's trying to do a buy. I'm trying to do a buy. He's trying to get a buy. Yeah. Well, I mean, did you ever worry when you were inside the dinosaurs mouth?
如果有人进来撞见你，你会说，比如，别走开？哦，那是个烂梗。哦，天哪。他在试图买下一个梗。我在试图买下一个梗。他在试图买下一个梗。是的。好吧，我的意思是，当你身处恐龙嘴里时，你有没有担心过
That it might somehow bite you? Bye! Thank you, Chicago! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you!
它可能会咬你？再见！谢谢你，芝加哥！谢谢！谢谢！谢谢！谢谢！谢谢！
Thank you! Thank you guys! Thank you! Thank you guys! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! Smartly crafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Granterry. It is every parent's nightmare when folding in South Jersey.
谢谢你们！谢谢大家！谢谢！谢谢大家！谢谢！谢谢！谢谢！谢谢！谢谢！谢谢！谢谢！谢谢！由罗布·阿姆朱夫、贝内特·巴巴科和迈克尔·格兰特里精心制作。在南泽西叠衣服时，这是每个父母的噩梦。
It's hard to imagine losing a loved one, a wife, a husband, a child. For many, it's their biggest fear. Amarissa Jones, host of The Vanished, a podcast that tells the stories of often overlooked and unsolved missing persons' cases. Every week, I dive into a new case, sharing the details of their mysterious disappearance, including interviews with family, friends, law enforcement, and even suspects, in an effort to reveal the truth. And I'm proud to say that this podcast has aided in a number of arrests.
很难想象失去所爱的人，妻子、丈夫、孩子。对许多人来说，这是他们最大的恐惧。阿玛丽莎·琼斯，播客《消失的人》的主持人，该节目讲述了常常被忽视且悬而未决的失踪人员案件。每周，我都深入探讨一个新案件，分享他们神秘失踪的细节，包括对家人、朋友、执法人员甚至嫌疑人的采访，以揭示真相。我很自豪地说，这个播客已经协助破获了多起逮捕行动。
It's important to me to remember the human behind the headline, and help family members find their vanished loved one, or at least a sense of peace. Follow the vanished wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on Amazon Music or the Wondery app. wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on Amazon Music or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对我来说，重要的是记住头条新闻背后的活生生的人，并帮助家属找到他们失踪的亲人，或者至少带来一丝平静。在您获取播客的任何地方关注《消失的人》。您可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery应用程序上收听无广告版。在您获取播客的任何地方。您可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery应用程序上收听无广告版。此剧集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。